1, 2, 3, 4.
Ich nie san xie.
Was war das denn?
Das war nur das Papier mit dem ich die mitgekriegt habe.
Hier ist das Chaosradio 52, zehn Minuten nach zehn haben wir's. Im Studio, Mitch, hallo. Andreas, ein schönen guten Abend. Pavel, du musst dich dann immer zum Mikrofon hin bewegen, wenn du was sagen willst.
Jaja, kein Problem.
Das hört sich aber gerade so an, als wär's eins. Sag noch mal was, ich stell dich mal lang. Ja, so geht das doch einigermaßen. Und Tim.
Hallo, ich bin auch da. Hör mich jetzt auch.
Du setzt dich doch gut. Ich will mal ein bisschen lauter. Das gibt mir ein gutes Gefühl.
Ich hör Stimmen.
Das sind unsere. Musik haben wir auch dabei und zwar eine Person, die Musik macht. Something's gonna happen. Something wonderful. Musik kommt heute Abend von Dr. Beatnik aus Hamburg. Und den würde ich jetzt einfach mal bitten loszulegen, dann kann ich deinen Regler aufmachen.
Nein, aber dieser Vorspann ist noch gar nicht fertig.
Das kann ich aber leiser machen.
Ich muss aber in unprofessioneller Radio mal raus.
Das sagt mein Chef auch immer, das ist irgendwie ganz komisch. Wir hatten da jetzt gesprochen.
Wir haben uns vorher zusammengesetzt und uns nichts eingefallen, aber wir dachten, du kannst sicherlich etwas beitragen.
Wenn ich von irgendwas einen Plan hab, dann von Programmiersprachen.
Ich verdiene damit ja Millionen.
Das ist doch auch so ein Internet Start-up, so ein Venture Capital.
Du hast das Nutzen Hobby hier alles.
Ja, sicher. Ich bin eigentlich der berühmteste HTML-Programmierer.
Genau, um das vorwegzunehmen, man kann in HTML nicht programmieren, weil in HTML man nicht mal bis drei zählen kann.
Dann schalte ich jetzt mal das Radio aus.
Es gibt da so gewisse Mindestanforderungen an Programmiersprachen. Dazu gehört, naja, also eigentlich bildet sich das alles auf Äh, Äquivalenz zu Touring-Maschinen ab. Aber grob gesprochen kann man sagen, wenn man Schleifen hat, beziehungsweise Rekursionen, was eigentlich dasselbe ist. Wenn man bedingte Anweisungen hat, dann hat man schon eine Programmiersprache. Und damit kann man sich alles andere im Notfall zusammenbauen. Und da man in HTML keine Schleifen hat, ist HTML keine Programmiersprachen.
Und das mit den Schleifen, das erklären wir aber nochmal, oder?
Genau.
Ja fangen wir doch mal damit an. Also ich hab ja, ich hab ja...
Hast du dir das deine Mutter nicht beigebracht?
Womit?
Na das mit den Schleifen.
Die hat mir noch ganz andere Sachen beigebracht. Ich hab mir gedacht, ich frag mal blöd, wie funktionieren eigentlich Computer? Also was macht es nötig, eine Programmiersprache zu haben?
Naja, also ganz unten drunter machen Computer eigentlich nichts anderes, außer Zahlen zusammen zu rechnen und dann zu gucken, ob das Ergebnis dieser Berechnung vielleicht null war oder nicht. Und dann wiederum andere Zahlen zusammen zu rechnen. Und also eigentlich eine sehr, sehr niedrige Abstraktion. Und um damit vernünftig arbeiten zu können, wurden Programmiersprachen erfunden. Es gibt also eine Schnittstelle zwischen der Hardware und der Software. Und die Anforderungen für diese Schnittstelle richten sich nach den Bedürfnissen der Maschine. Und Programmiersprachen existieren deshalb, weil sie die Bedürfnisse des Programmierers adressieren. Das heißt, Programmiersprachen sind eigentlich ein Übergang von der Art und Weise, wie der Programmierer an ein Problem rangeht und dem, wie die Maschine das Problem lösen wird. Sozusagen eine Übersetzung zwischen beiden.
Also sie kann das Problem auch eigentlich nur... Machst du mal dein Handy aus?
Bereits passiert.
Willkommen im Rundfunk. Aber die Maschine kann auch eigentlich immer nur das selbe, oder? Also die Maschine ist doch nur in der Lage, dieselben Berechnungen rauszuführen, oder nicht? Also das heißt, letztlich macht ja jede Programmiersprache führt in Computer dann also auf einer niedrigeren Ebene dazu, dass der immer wieder das selbe macht.
Darunter versteht man halt den Code, den der Prozessor tatsächlich liest, aus dem Speicher, der in diesem RAM abgelegt ist, oder eben in übersetzten Programmen entsprechend in den Dateien und dann ins RAM geladen wird und dann vom RAM in den Prozessor, in seine Instruktionspipelines geladen wird und dort ausgeführt wird. Das sind halt spezielle Nummerncodes, die sowas bedeuten wie, addiere dieses auf jenes und multipliziere mal was und jetzt hast du hier irgendwie ein Stück Speicher und von da nach da kopierst du das und das und das und jetzt guckst du mal, ob das eine Null ist und wenn das eine Null ist, dann machst du das und wenn das keine Null ist, dann machst du gar nichts oder auch was anderes und jetzt wartest du irgendwie mal, bis das Ergebnis einer anderen Operation stimmt und so ganz niedere Sachen, in denen man halt auch nicht wirklich programmieren möchte.
Das ist das, was man früher immer in seinen 64er so eingetypt hat, oder?
Richtig. Also in den 80er Jahren war das noch durchaus opportun und angesagt beziehungsweise auch notwendig, in Maschinensprache zu programmieren, weil man eigentlich nur so die notwendige Geschwindigkeit für Spieler und andere Anwendungen hinbekommen hat. Abgesehen davon bot auch so ein Computer wie ein C64, man hatte 64K Hauptspeicher, das kann man sich heute gar nicht mehr vorstellen, jedes Icon auf dem Desktop verbraucht, mittlerweile schon mehr Platz. Aber es gab auch gar nicht so viele Tools für höhere Programmiersprachen. Es gab halt Basic, das war eigentlich aber auch das, in dem meistens programmiert wurde. Dieses Basic wurde dann eben zur Laufzeit interpretiert, also von einem Stück Software, was in den Computer fest eingebaut war, sozusagen umgesetzt und letzten Endes dann aber auch in Maschinensprache Befehle übersetzt. Oder umgesetzt, nicht wirklich übersetzt.
Aber eigentlich ist die Geschichte der Programmiersprache ja viel, viel älter. Es gab ja nicht nur die Heimcomputer in den 80ern, sondern davor noch jede Menge Großrechnerentwicklung. Das ging also alles schwer in den 50ern los. Nee, eigentlich noch viel früher. Die erste Programmiersprache, die sich jemand ausgedacht hat, aber nicht umgesetzt hat, war Plankalkül. Das war eine Sprache, die Konrad Zuse sich ausgedacht hat und die als die Programmiersprache seines Z3 gelten sollte, dass die Programmiersprache dafür werden sollte. Es gab davon, glaube ich, nie eine wirkliche Umsetzung. Also mittlerweile gibt es wohl einen Plankalkül-Compiler, aber damals noch nicht. Und zu den ersten Programmiersprachen, die dann tatsächlich benutzt wurden, hat jemand die Jahreszahlen irgendwo? Keiner hat die Jahreszahlen.
Hier habe ich die nicht drin, auf dem Zettel.
Aber vielleicht hast du noch die Worte.
Ah, du hast das auf dem Rechner, ne? Genau. Wir schlagen das nach im Buch der Waffen.
Genau, also Fortran war eine relativ alte Programmiersprache. Cobol ist eine sehr alte Programmiersprache und auch Lisp ist relativ alt. Also das sind die ersten sogenannten High-Level-Programmiersprachen, die also nicht einfach 1 zu 1 Umsetzung der Maschinensprache waren, sondern wo tatsächlich neue Abstraktionen, neue Sprachkonstrukte eingeführt wurden. Also es gab da noch einen Zwischenschritt dazwischen und zwar von der Maschinensprache zum Assembler. Maschinensprache war so, manche Leute kennen das vielleicht noch aus frühen C64-Zeiten, da waren dann seitenweise Hex-Codes, in diese Hex-Codes konnte man abtippen und dann ausführen. Das ist Maschinensprache. Bei Assembler ist das ein bisschen freundlicher. Da heißt es dann, da darf man dann Red schreiben statt C3 und gewinnt dadurch schon mal ein bisschen Bequemlichkeit, aber die Features sind noch dieselben. Und erst die High-Level-Sprachen führen so Abstraktionen ein wie Funktionsaufrufe. Also man kann zwar auch in Assembler hin und her springen, aber auch wild und ungeordnet. Und das Geordnete kam dann erst mit den höheren Programmiersprachen.
Ja, jetzt haben wir hier die ganzen Jahreszahlen. Also 1957 mit Fordran hat es im Prinzip richtig angefangen und ging dann Schlag auf Schlag. 58 mit Algol, 60 mit Lisp und Kobol weiter. Und dann so die bis 70 waren dann noch APL, Simula, BASIC, PL1 dabei. Das sind, glaube ich, alles ziemlich bekannte Vertreter. Und dann ging es...
Allerdings alle ziemlich unterschiedliche Ansätze haben. Also es sind nicht schon Sprachen, die aufeinander aufgebaut haben, sondern in dieser Frühzeit gab es ganz unterschiedliche Wissenschaftler und Hacker, die halt irgendwie bestimmte Problemlösungen gesucht haben, vor allem in Hochsprachen. Und das waren halt alles andere Ansätze.
Ja, man kann sagen, Fortran war sozusagen der Vorgänger von BASIC, beziehungsweise BASIC eine bisschen abgewandelte, einfache Reform als mathematische Programmiersprache. Allwohl eigentlich eine sehr elegante Sprache, die irgendwo als Vorgänger oder Urvater von Pascal mitgelten kann. Sehr schön, um ja doch komplexe Algorithmen auszudrücken. Lisp nach wie vor der Liebling der KI. Und Kobol als die Sprache, wo man mit Datenbanken und Bildschirmmasken besonders gut umgehen kann. Ja, weiß jemand ein bisschen was über APL?
War APL nicht die Sprache, wo man wunderbar Einzeller schreiben konnte, die dann tolle Dinge taten, mit ganz vielen wirren Sonderzeichen?
Das war glaube ich PL1.
Der Fritz-Stream ist irgendwie ausgefallen, haben wir gehört.
Ja, das ist also der Router, der meint, dass es irgendwie in nicht regelmäßigen Abständen sinnvoll wäre, sich mal zu booten.
Das ist bestimmt ein Sicherheitsfeature.
Genau. Und wir haben jetzt also schon jemanden in Trab gesetzt, der sich darum bemüht. Möglicherweise ist das ja auch schon fertig.
Das ist schön, wir haben auch ein paar Leute in Trab gesetzt und haben einen ohnehin notwendigen MP3-Streamer aufgesetzt. Und ihr könnt daran teilnehmen. Allerdings sagen wir euch nicht genau, wie die URL lautet, sondern ihr müsst euch schon dazu in den IRC bequemen. Und Irknet ist das, ne?
Nee, das ist nicht Irknet. Das ist irc.ccc.de als Server Channel Chaosradio. Und einfach nicht fragen. Wir haben halt nur eine bestimmte Anzahl Slots wegen begrenzter Bandbreite, weil es ja leider leider noch keinen Multicast gibt bei unseren lieben ISPs.
Also irc.ccc.de als IRC-Server eintragen und dann haben wir den Channel Chaosradio und da sitzen freundliche Hacker, die euch zum richtigen Server geleiten. Und wir haben 42 Slots frei und ihr könnt dabei sein. Wie schnell?
Ich weiß nicht genau, ich gehe mal davon aus, dass ein 56 Kilobit drin ist.
Das war deine Frage.
Was?
Wir werden dafür sorgen, dass deine Fragen noch ausreichend gedient werden, bevor wir dann uns auf die Details stellen.
Ich dachte, das wären schon die Details gewesen. Nein, also ich dachte mir, ich frag mal, weil wahrscheinlich lachen jetzt ganz viele und ihr auch, aber ich verstehe wirklich nicht, wie so ein Computer, also was macht der? Was passiert da innen drin? Wo läuft da Strom lang und was macht der Strom, der da läuft?
Also im Wesentlichen sind es zwei Dinge. Das wichtigste an jedem Computer ist der Zähler oder die Zähler. Der zählt nämlich Programmschritte und Speicheradressen. Zählen ist eine ganz wichtige Sache. Typischerweise halt so ein 32-Bit-Rechner kann dann eben Zahlen mit 32 Bits, also bis ungefähr 4 Milliarden zählen, so relativ schnell. Man kann natürlich noch mehr zählen, aber bis 4 Milliarden kann er das einigermaßen fix. Und dann kann er die Zahlen, die Zählerstände irgendwo abspeichern oder sich die Zählerstände irgendwo in den Speicher schreiben oder die Zählerstände aus dem Speicher lesen. Und dann kann er noch Zählerstände im Prinzip vergleichen. So auf ist es 0 oder nicht, größer 0. Und addieren und subtrahieren ist meistens auch noch relativ schnell. Aber das ist schon Luxus. Eigentlich reicht zählen und gucken, ob er bei 0 angekommen ist. Das ist schon genug.
Aber woher weiß der, dass er ein A schreiben soll?
Na das weiß er nicht wirklich. Das mit dem A ist eigentlich nur eine ganz bestimmte Zahl. Und je nachdem, es gibt halt auch einen bestimmten Speicher, der dann auf mehr oder weniger komplizierte Art auf einen Schirm geworfen wird. Und wenn in diesem Speicher an bestimmten Stellen Nullen oder Einsen stehen, dann tauchen die als kleine Lichtpünktchen auf dem Bildschirm auf. Nullen sind dann schwarz und Einsen sind weiß. Und wenn er jetzt eben ein A schreiben soll, dann muss er die entsprechenden Pünktchen schwarz und weiß an- und ausknipsen, sodass man sich dann einbildet, ein A zu sehen. Aber erstmal, dass das ein A ein A ist, weiß der Rechner erst mal gar nicht.
Und das speichert er dann, also dafür dann Grafikspeicher?
Oder?
Ja, also man hat bestimmt eine Ebene.
Man verlässt halt den Zahlenbereich in dem Moment, wo man anfängt, Codes, also Zuordnungen zu definieren. Dass ein A ein A ist, ist für den Prozessor irrelevant. Er kennt einfach nur Zahlen, weil das ist das ein Computer. Heißt halt Computer, weil er sich mit Zahlen beschäftigt, ist halt ein Rechner. Buchstaben sind nicht seine Nummer, sondern man wendet einfach dann die Tatsache, dass man Zahlen hat, an, um einen Code zu haben. Und da ist dann einfach festgelegt worden, dass ein A, ein großes A, ist halt die 65. Wenn irgendwo im Speicher eine 65 steht und diese 65 wird benutzt, um irgendeinem Gerät, wie zum Beispiel einem Drucker, zu sagen, was er drucken soll, dann interpretiert er halt die 65 als ein A und wählt dann halt das entsprechende Typenrad aus und macht Klack. Oder auf dem Bildschirm entsprechend wird das dann halt glühend.
Genau und das B ist die 66, zufällig. Jedenfalls beim ASCII-Code.
Es gibt auch andere Codes.
Da weiß ich doch schon mal ein bisschen mehr jetzt.
Genau, und da das halt eigentlich ein relativ... Naja, also für den Prozess ist es natürlich optimal, solch komplexe Dinge wie rechnen, in möglichst einfachen Schritten auszuführen. Aber wenn man jetzt so ein abstraktes Problem lösen möchte wie was ist der kürzeste Weg, um in meiner Wohnung mit dem Staubsauger irgendwie alles zu reinigen, ohne dass ich halt irgendwie alles zwei und dreimal sauge. Und dass ich irgendwie auch immer die richtigen Abstände zu passenden Steckdosen habe. Wenn man so ein Problem lösen möchte, ist es ein bisschen schwierig, irgendwie auf Ebene von Zählern einzusteigen, sondern möchte man eigentlich möglichst abstrakt an die Sache herangehen und sagen, gesetzt sei es gibt einen Staubsauger und der hat irgendwie ein Stromkabel und es gibt irgendwie folgende Betriebsparameter, wenn irgendwie Steckdose weiter weg als Stromkabel lang, dann schwierig und daraus Radios und das ist eigentlich das Gebäude, mit dem man arbeitet. Und eine gute Programmiersprache ist halt für den Zweck angemessen. Es gibt halt viele Sprachen, nicht zuletzt deshalb, weil es viele Zwecke gibt, für die man einen Computer einsetzt und für viele Zwecke sind halt unterschiedliche Programmiersprachen gut. Für das Staubsaugerproblem möchte man halt eigentlich eine Sprache haben, wie Prolog oder so, wo man irgendwie die Aussage, was man eigentlich haben will, an den Anfang stellt und dann die Rahmenbedingungen noch definiert und den Rest denkt er sich dann irgendwie selber. Aber wenn es nur darum geht, irgendwie eine Reihe von Lampen irgendwie so ein Lauflicht zu programmieren oder so, das kann man dann vielleicht sogar noch in Maschinensprache lösen. Weil das ist eigentlich ein sehr einfacher Vorgang, der auch an der Natur des Computers sehr nah dran ist. Durchziehen und an und aus.
Ja, kommen wir kurz zur Realität. Okay, es ist nämlich 22 Uhr 32.
Reaktion, die Bundesregierung will schärfer gegen Neonazis vorgehen. Bundesinnenminister Schiedi kündigte heute in Berlin eine Beratung mit Vertretern vom Innenjustiz- und Jugendministerium an. Brandenburgs Innenminister Schönbohm hat indessen gefordert, rechtsextremistische Gewalttäter rascher zu bestrafen. Untersuchung nach einer anonymen Telefondrohung mit rechtem Terror ist ein Berliner Polizeibeamter vom Dienst suspendiert worden. Der Anruf ging von seinem Privatanschluss ab. Da der Polizist die Tat bestreitet, soll eine Stimmenanalyse durchgeführt werden, heißt es. Anlauf. Am ersten Auktionstag haben die Bieter für die deutschen UTMS Mobilfunklizenzen Verhalten begonnen. Am Abend lagen die Gebote unter drei Milliarden Mark. Die Bundesregierung erhofft sich einen wesentlich höheren Erlös. Preisanstieg. Ab morgen müssen die Fahrgäste im Gebiet des Verkehrsverbundes Berlin Brandenburg wieder tiefer in die Tasche greifen. Die Tickets werden um vier bis fünf Prozent teurer. Formel 1. Der Chef des Lausitzringes Fischer rechnet nicht mehr mit dem Zuschlag für den großen Preis von Deutschland. Auch nach einem Gespräch mit Formel 1 Boss Applestone sieht er keine Chance mehr, den Lauf schon ab 2002 von Hockenheim nach Ostdeutschland zu holen.
Wetter.
In dieser Nacht bei uns Temperaturen zwischen 14 und 10 Grad am Tag dann halbwegs heiter. 23 bis 27 Grad.
Herzlichen Dank, Matthias Karkow.
Pritz pritz präsentiert. Einen Abend.
Chaosradio 52 ist das, was wir hier hören, also beziehungsweise das ist gerade Musik, die Dr. Bietnick aus Hamburg auflegt. Wir befinden uns im Chaosradio 52 und wir, nein nicht wir, ihr redet über Programmierfragen und ich höre staunend zu. Ihr, das ist Tim, Pavel, Andreas und Mitch, der heute irgendwie noch gar nichts gesagt hat.
Doch, ein bisschen schon, aber...
Okay, das reicht auch. Danke, Iskman.
Spezialismus aus Detailfragen.
Ja, dann lass uns doch mal in die Details, oder?
Ja, welche möchtest du denn haben, beziehungsweise was UMTS heißt?
Ja genau, ich wüsste gerne, was UTMS heißt. Ja und vor allen Dingen ist es eigentlich auch egal, es braucht kein Mensch.
Doch, das brauchen wir alle. Also wir wollen das alle schon seit 10 Jahren haben. Es ist ziemlich schlimm, dass es jetzt noch weitere 5 Jahre dauert, bis wir es kriegen.
Ja und dann nicht bezahlen können.
Na ja, das konnten wir irgendwie für die Telefonleitung von der Telekom auch nicht wirklich.
Ja, aber da war es einfacher, sie nicht zu bezahlen. Soll ich jetzt mal den Zettel abarbeiten, den du mir gegeben hast? Also ich tippe jetzt einfach mal irgendwo rein und da steht GLIP.
Nein, bei mir?
Bei mir steht GLIP.
Das ist aber jetzt schon zu weit.
Na bei GLIP muss man ein bisschen ausholen. Also es ist so, dass verschiedene Programmiersprachen, verschiedene Abstraktionen unterstützen von Dingen, die man sowieso in seiner Programmiersprache tut. Also die Leute, die früher in Ascender programmiert haben, haben irgendwann mal festgestellt, dass sie bestimmte Code Konstrukte, bestimmte Arten und Weisen, Code zu schreiben, immer und immer wieder verwenden. Das ist was, was man heutzutage als Pattern bezeichnet. Und diese Patterns werden dann irgendwann zu Features von Programmiersprachen, wenn sich allgemein die Einsicht durchgesetzt hat, dass es sinnvoll ist, das so zu machen. Also eines der ersten Patterns, was sozusagen vom expliziten Programmieren implizit in die Sprache gekommen ist, sind Funktionsaufrufe. Dass man eine Funktion rekursiv aufrufen kann. Also in Assembler gibt es erstmal nur Sprünge. Und zwar sogenannte unbedingte Sprünge. Das heißt, es wird auf jeden Fall an eine bestimmte Stelle im Programmcode gesprungen. Und bedingte Sprünge. Das heißt, man springt nur manchmal. Und ein Funktionsaufruf ist jetzt eine Abstraktion, dass ich an eine bestimmte Stelle im Programm springe. Dort wird die Funktion abgearbeitet. Und dann springe ich dahin zurück, wo ich herkomme. Und wo ich herkomme, merke ich mir in einem anderen Register oder auf einem Stack. Und so ist der Funktionsaufruf entstanden. Man kann natürlich auch anders programmieren. Das ist das, was man heutzutage als Spaghetti Code bezeichnet. Das heißt, man kann einfach davon ausgehen, wenn man an einer bestimmten Stelle angekommen ist, dass man ja weiß, wo der herkommt, und dann wiederum an einer dritten Stelle zurückspringen oder ähnliche Geschichten. Und es gab dann ein Paper von Dykstra mit dem Namen Go To Considered Harmful, was dem Treiben ein Ende gesetzt hat, mehr oder weniger. Und die ersten Programmiersprachen unterstützten halt als Abtraktion Subroutinen. Und alles andere war dann so mehr oder weniger eine 1 zu 1 Abbildung auf die darunter liegende Hardware. Also im Vortran hat man halt mathematische Operationen, so plus, minus, mal, durch. Und genau das stellt die Hardware 1 zu 1 auch bereit. Und um zu deiner Frage zurückzukommen, Gielip ist also eine...
Das war keine Frage, ich hab einfach nur ein Wort vorgelesen, das ich gesehen hab.
Warte mal, vielleicht sollte man kurz mal festhalten, also eine Subroutine ist sozusagen etwas wirklich sehr alltägliches im Programm. Das ist halt einfach nur, dass man etwas, was man ohnehin häufiger tut in seinem Programm, aber vielleicht immer mit kleinen Abweichungen, dass man das an einer einzigen Stelle zu Code zusammenfasst, der halt an den Stellen, wo man es dann braucht, aufgerufen wird. Also so ein A auf dem Bildschirm auszunehmen. Das ist ein typisches Merkmal des Programmierens an sich, dass man halt eine Abstraktion schafft. A, ich schreibe jetzt hier Code, der tut etwas, was ich häufiger tue, aber er ist eben auch so variabel, indem ich ihm zum Beispiel Parameter mitgebe, die er dann anschauen kann und mit in seine Art und Weise einflächen kann.
Also eine wichtige Eigenschaft für Programmierer ist die Faulheit, sodass man möglichst dasselbe nur einmal hinschreibt und anschließend Wiederholungen davon möglichst vermeidet, beziehungsweise alles, was man wiederholt hinschreiben kann, kann man auch einmal hinschreiben und sagt dann besser dem Rechner, er soll es dann zweimal oder dreimal oder wie oft auch immer tun.
Da sagt der Dau jetzt, Makro, Makro, das ist im Prinzip, oder? Im Prinzip sowas wie ein Makro, wenn ich ihn gehört habe.
Ein Makro ist eine simple Art von so einer Wiederholungsleistung.
Genau. Wiederholungsvermeidungsleistung.
Wiederholungsvermeidungsleistung, genau.
Also wenn man Makro benutzt, dann hat man im Prinzip schon programmiert. Also viele Leute schrecken vor dem Programmieren zurück, oh, das ist kompliziert, da hat man es mit viel Wissenschaft zu tun und irgendwie viel arbeiten, alles furchtbar unverständlich. Aber dieselben Leute haben dann kein Problem, irgendeine Scriptingsprache zu benutzen. Aber in Wirklichkeit ist es genau dasselbe, was man da tut. Nur, dass Scriptingsprachen sich schon auf einem sehr hohen Abstraktionsgrad befinden. Und dass die meisten Scriptingsprachen nicht elegant auf die tatsächlich vorhandene Hardware-Schnittstelle, nämlich irgendwie Registermaschine, abzubilden sind. Und das ist deshalb alles furchtbar schlecht performt. Aber Makro ist im Prinzip schon programmieren.
Chaosradio 52, wir reden über Programmiersprachen und da hatte ich eben eine Frage. Skrittensprachen hast du gesagt, Programmiersprachen, also inwiefern unterscheiden die sich?
Dass sich die Musik so schlagartig ändert.
Ja, war der Unterschied.
Das merkt man zum Beispiel, wenn man im Web surft, wie das ja heutzutage heißt.
Wie nennst du das?
Netzen, was weiß ich?
Drinnen sein.
Drinnen.
Also wenn ich drinnen bin, dann habe ich manchmal so die Erfahrung, dass Webseiten sich allzu aufdringlich verhalten, indem sie anfangen zu blinken und Dinge zu tun, wenn ich die Maus über sie rüber schiebe und so. Das kann ja ganz lustig aussehen. Den Grund dafür ist das nicht selten, die Programmiersprache JavaScript verwendet wurde, die mit den HTML Seiten an den Browser übergeben werden. Und der führt dann sozusagen den Code, nachdem er diese Seite erhalten hat, mit den ganzen Funktionen, die da drin definiert sind, aus im Kontext dieser Webseite, sodass das Programm Dinge austauschen kann, Eingaben überprüfen kann, solche Sachen machen kann. Das Scriptsprache ist also eine, eigentlich eine sehr nah am Benutzer liegende Programmiersprache, die halt in der Regel, es ist auch eine ganz normale Programmiersprache. Man nennt sie nur dann eine Scriptsprache, wenn sie halt nicht dafür gedacht ist, wirklich Anwendungen, die auf dem Betriebssystem direkt laufen, zu entwickeln, sondern eigentlich mehr, um ein schon bereits bestehendes Programm in seiner Funktion, die es bietet, zu automatisieren. Und dann nennt man das eben Scripting. Java Script ist ein Beispiel dafür.
Die Grenzen inzwischen sind auch relativ fließend. Also früher unterschickt man komponierte Sprachen und interpretierte Sprachen. Also komponierte Sprachen sind solche, die von vornherein in Maschinencode umgesetzt werden. Interpretierte Sprachen sind so, dass da ein Programm gibt, der das Programm ausführt und sich Zeile für Zeile aktuell anguckt und aktuell entscheidet, was zu tun ist. Und es ist so, dass interpretierte Sprachen und Skriptsprachen sich ein bisschen überschneiden. Es ist nicht immer möglich, Sprachkonstrukte effizient auf Hardware abzubilden. Deshalb tut man das nicht, sondern nimmt einen Interpreter. Aber es ist halt so, dass die Compiler-Technik fortgeschritten ist und man jetzt auch mittlerweile höhere Programmiersprachen kompilen kann, auch Skriptsprachen kompilen kann. Andererseits kann man mit klassischen Skriptsprachen auch ganze Applikationen schreiben. Also zum Beispiel Emacs ist ein sehr beliebter Editor. Emacs lässt sich in Emacs Lisp skripten. Und es gibt also komplette numerische Systeme, die Differentialgleichungen lösen können in Emacs Skript. Es gibt da einen Mail-Reader und einen News-Reader und einen Irglind und eine FTP-Software und sogar einen Webbrowser, die in dieser Skriptingsprache geschrieben sind. Das heißt auch die Einschränkung, man kann damit keine Applikationen machen, ist sehr relativ.
Also nicht, man kann sie nicht damit machen, sondern sie sind nicht im Wesentlichen dafür gedacht, aber es ist eben auch möglich. Man kann auch alles in Assembler programmieren, aber das ist wirklich für die harten.
Und Lisp ist halt eine Sprache, wo man beides hat. Lisp lässt sich auf der einen Seite kompilieren in sehr effizientem Code, der es durchaus mit C-Code aufnehmen kann. Auf der anderen Seite kann man mit Lisp oder auch Schemes, das ist eine Lisp-Variante, sehr gut Applikationen skripten, weil es auf einer sehr hohen Ebene ansetzt. Von der Benutzbarkeit her, vom dieser Verständnis her.
Ja, ein wichtiges Merkmal an Skriptsprachen ist auch typischerweise das sogenannte Late Binding. Das heißt, dass verschiedene Komponenten und Programme erst in dem Moment, wo sie ausgeführt werden, tatsächlich zusammenkommen. Das heißt, einen ganz kurzen Moment vorher müssen sie sich noch gar nicht kennen. Das heißt, sie können dazu geladen oder sogar erzeugt werden. Also Skript Sprachen können zum Beispiel auch sich selber erzeugen oder verändern, typischerweise. Also eine Skript Sprache, ein Merkmal einer Skript Sprache ist typischerweise, dass diese Skript Sprache sich selber erzeugen kann oder man Ausdrücke in dieser Skript Sprache erzeugen kann.
Ja, Chaosradio 52, wir reden über Programmiersprachen und Marc hat angerufen, hat eine Frage.
Ich hab keine Frage, ich hab ein bisschen...
Eine Antwort.
Du hast eine Antwort?
Ich wollte was erzählen. Ja, es ist noch so viel gesprochen über Programmiersprachen, daß die solche Viren erzeugen können. Es gibt Sachen, die können in allen Plattformen angreifen.
Was?
Es gibt Viren, die können in allen Plattformen angreifen.
HTML ist ja nicht mal eine Programmiersprache.
Dann lege ich mir die Prätersprache, aber man kann Viren schreiben.
Aber nicht in HTML.
HTML und ClipTing-Sprachen, die für HTML geschrieben werden.
Natürlich kann man wunderschöne HTML-Viren schreiben. Das ist ein Text, da steht dann irgendwie, wenn Sie diese Seite sehen und Sie nicht an all Ihre Freunde in Ihrem Adressbuch schicken, dann passiert morgen was ganz Furchtbares mit Ihnen.
Aber Blinken ist doch ein Virus.
Aber das hat jetzt mit Programmiersprachen wirklich nichts zu tun.
Also du kannst mit jeder Programmiersprache irgendwas programmieren, was irgendwie Scheiße baut. Das ist dann auch häufig irgendwie der Fall. Und man kann mit jeder Programmiersprache was anderes machen.
Also jede interessante Programmiersprache ist mächtig genug, um da mit einem Virus zu schreiben, aber Viren sind eigentlich gar nicht das Thema heute.
Und Computerviren sind auch nicht wirklich gefährlich. Also im Vergleich zu anderen.
Im Vergleich zu was denn? Sind Viren nicht schlimm?
Na zu Viren, die so richtig an die Materie gehen. Also biologische Viren halt. Also Todesfälle durch Computerviren sind mir bisher noch nicht bekannt geworden.
Also insofern meine Festplatte fressen würde, wenn es mir danach nicht besonders gut geht.
Ja gut, aber da gibt es viel wahrscheinlichere Szenarien, wo irgendwas deine Festplatte frisst als ein Virus.
Mein Computer.
Dein Betriebssystem zum Beispiel.
Das Fallsystem, ja das ist der Fall.
Ja Und zwar das Chaosradio 52 mit dem Thema Computersprache, Programmiersprachen, Computersprachen, sehr schön. Was steht denn auf Ihrem Monitor? Programmiersprachen und eben kam auf der Unterschied zwischen Menschensprache und Programmiersprache. Welcher ist es?
Naja, da gibt es doch ziemlich große Unterschiede. Erstmal sind Programmiersprachen vergleichsweise einfach und haben viel viel weniger Worte als eine menschliche Sprache. Typische Programmiersprache hat zwischen 20 und 200 sogenannte Keywords. Mehr ist das erstmal nicht. Das heißt, die Vokabeln sind sehr sehr schnell gelernt. Also die hat man an einem Tag, hat man im Prinzip alle Vokabeln einer Programmiersprache drin. Und man kann wirklich durchaus an einem Tag eine Programmiersprache so lernen, dass man sich darin ausdrücken kann zumindest. Natürlich sie wirklich zu beherrschen in all ihren Feinheiten kann Jahrzehnte dauern, aber wenn man es überhaupt schafft, aber das ist vielleicht schon mal ein wesentlicher Unterschied. Und dann ist es so, dass Programmiersprachen nicht so sehr lebendig sind von Visual Basic, vielleicht mal abgesehen, aber ansonsten ist es relativ genau festgelegt, wie Sätze gebildet werden dürfen und wie nicht in dieser Programmiersprache. Und zwar so festgelegt, dass es möglichst eindeutig ist. Das klappt zwar auch nicht immer, aber das ist so der wesentliche Unterschied. Also Programmiersprachen sind doch eine sehr, sehr vereinfachte mathematische Sicht der Welt mit relativ wenig Vokabeln und wenig Spielraum.
Allerdings gibt es auch eine ganze Reihe Gemeinsamkeiten, und zwar sowohl menschliche Sprachen als auch Programmiersprachen besitzen eine Syntax und eine Semantik. Syntax ist sowas wie Grammatik, das heißt, welche Sprachkonstrukte sind zugelassen, so Subjekt, Prädikat, Objekt, Nebensätze, Verknüpfung von Hauptsätzen und so weiter und so fort, Subjekt, Objekt, Prädikat. Ähnliche Konzepte gibt es auch in Programmiersprachen, und manche davon heißen sogar gleich. Also es gibt zum Beispiel Blöcke. Blöcke sind sowas wie Sätze in Programmiersprachen. Das heißt, man hat eine Reihe von Instruktionen, die halt nacheinander kommen und die dürfen geschachtelt sein. Es gibt dann IF-Abfragen, und die IF-Abfragen müssen eine Bedingung haben, einen Teil, der ausgeführt wird, wenn die Bedingung wahr ist, und einen Teil, der ausgeführt wird, wenn die Bedingung falsch ist, und so weiter und so fort. Und die Art und Weise, wie ich die Wörter miteinander kombinieren kann, ist die Syntax der Sprache und das, was dann passiert, also was bedeutet das, wenn ich ein IF-Konstrukt verwende, das ist die Semantik. Und bei menschlichen Sprachen ist es so, dass die Semantik nicht immer eindeutig ist. Also es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen was willst du schon wieder und was willst du schon wieder. Also obwohl es dieselben Wörter sind, obwohl es dieselben Wörter sind, ist die Bedeutung eine völlig verschiedene. Was willst du schon wieder? Programmiersprachen nicht, die sind relativ eindeutig festgelegt, was da passiert. Jedenfalls sollte man das hoffen. Frühe Versionen des C++ Compilers namens C-Front, da war es dann so, dass die Beschreibung der Programmiersprache gewisse Fälle offen gelassen hat. Und wenn man das dann mal ausprobiert hat, in den Compiler reingeschmissen hat, dann ist der Compiler abgestürzt. Also sowas gibt es auch, ist aber nicht die Regel.
Da hat er sich gefragt, was willst du denn schon wieder.
Ist doch eigentlich ein nettes Konzept für die Menschheit, dass man sich nur die richtigen Worte um die Ohren haut und dann stürzt man gemeinsam ab.
Es gibt natürlich auch Fälle in der natürlichen Sprache, wo die Semantik sehr eindeutig definiert ist. Zum Beispiel Gesetzestexte sind nicht etwa im normalen Deutsch verfasst, sondern in Juristendeutsch. Das heißt, jeder Begriff ist definiert, hat eine bestimmte Bedeutung und wenn man darüber redet, dann gibt es den nun nur in dieser Bedeutung. Zum Beispiel das Wort grundsätzlich bedeutet irgendetwas in Juristendeutsch. Und interessanterweise gibt es da Unterschiede zwischen Ost- und Westrecht. Also im Ostrecht war es so, vor zehn Jahren, als es die DDR noch gab, dass grundsätzlich bedeutete grundsätzlich und es gibt von dem Grundsatz keine Ausnahmen. Und im Westjuristendeutsch ist es so, dass grundsätzlich bedeutet, dass es standardmäßig so gemacht wird, wie es grundsätzlich gemacht wird, aber es gibt Ausnahmen. Und dementsprechend ist es auch schwierig, wenn man einen Gesetzestext liest, den als Laie zu interpretieren. Und deswegen gibt es dafür Fachleute.
Unterschiedliche Semantik.
So ich hab jetzt zu Hause hab ich zwei Rechner stehen, ein Mac und ein PC und jetzt will ich was programmieren. Also ich weiß nicht was, aber ich will jetzt programmieren können. Also wie lernt man programmieren? Wie werde ich Hacker?
Ja mit dem Hacker ist das noch eine andere Sache, aber...
Okay, wie lerne ich programmieren? Aber womit sollte ich einsteigen?
Das ist eigentlich völlig egal. So nimm irgendeine. Du solltest sowieso jedes Jahr eine neue Programmiersprache wenigstens dazu lernen. Also wenn du erstmal wichtig ist, dass du mit irgendeiner anfängst und...
Da du gleich kleben bleibst.
Ja und wonach du dich richtest, also ob du... Ich mein Java ist durchaus eine ganz nette Sache. Du kannst aber auch mit Basic beginnen oder du kannst auch mit Pascal anfangen.
Auch Javascript.
Warum ist es so beliebt?
Na Pearl ist so beliebt, weil es umsonst ist. Eine relativ mächtige Sprache ist, mit der man zum Beispiel Strings sehr gut bearbeiten kann, die auf allen Plattformen verfügbar ist und die sehr auf einem sehr sehr hohen Level ist. Also es ist eine Scriptingsprache und relativ einfach zu lernen. Man muss sich nicht mit irgendwelchen Bitrepräsentationen und Pointern und Speicherverwaltung rumschlagen. Also es gibt halt Sprachen, da muss man seinen Speicher selbst verwalten. Es gibt Sprachen, da wird der Speicher automatisch verwaltet und wenn man den Speicher selbst verwaltet, hat man natürlich mehr Kontrolle darüber, wie er verwaltet wird, aber man hat auch mehr zu tun, um dasselbe Ziel zu erreichen.
Also Pearl ist schon so ein bisschen hardcore, muss man aber dazu sagen. Weil in Pearl ist so die Programmiersprache, wo man mit die kürzesten Programme schreiben kann, die eine bestimmte Aufgabe erfüllen. Das heißt, was in einer anderen Programmiersprache vielleicht 30 Zeilen braucht, kann man in Pearl oft gut und gerne auf drei Zeilen zusammen stutzen.
Die sind dann natürlich nicht mehr lesbar.
Die Lesbarkeit leidet enorm, ja. Aber das ist auch ein besonderer Sportaspekt bei Pearl.
Es reicht ja, wenn's maschinenlesbar ist.
Also Java ist eigentlich, wenn man nicht so viel kaputt machen will, ist Java vielleicht eine ganz gute Wahl, weil da sind viele Kindersicherungen eingebaut. Und das ist auch, ich sag mal, andererseits eine Sprache, die ganz gut dokumentiert ist, wo man in etwa weiß, was passieren sollte. Und für einen Einstieg, würde ich heute sagen, ist Java eine ganz, ganz gute Wahl.
Wichtig ist halt, dass man dabei nicht stehen bleibt. Man sollte eigentlich aus jeder wichtigen Klasse von Programmiersprachen mindestens eine gelernt haben. Und was mir da an Sachen einfällt sind zum Beispiel procedurale Sprachen. Da kommt C in Frage als immer noch sehr, sehr wichtige Sprache. C ist nur ein ganz kleines bisschen abstrakter als Assembler. Man könnte es als High-Level Assembler bezeichnen. Aber 95 Prozent aller real existierenden Programme sind in C geschrieben. Und es ist deshalb ganz interessant, das zu kennen, weil man dann viel Programmcode von anderen Leuten lesen kann.
Und ich finde, dass man bei C am ehesten versteht, wie die Maschine eigentlich arbeitet. Du bist ganz nah an der Hardware. Du benutzt die Betriebssystemkurs direkt, nicht über irgendwelche Abstraction-Layers.
Ja, wobei dann kann man auch gleich mit C++ anfangen. Also C kann man dann eigentlich...
Weil C++ macht gewisse objektorientierte Aspekte schlecht bzw. falsch. Ich denke, man sollte eine reine prozedurale Sprache wie C machen und dann auch mal eine reine objektorientierte Sprache. Also Smalltalk zum Beispiel, Java ist eigentlich auch ganz gut geeignet. Dillon natürlich, Kloss, Common Lisp Object System. Also es gibt da einige, die eher in Frage kommen, bevor ich C++ empfehlen würde.
Was bedeutet objektorientiert?
Ähm...
Objektorientiert...
Da haben wir auch lange gedrückt.
Es sind verschiedene Aspekte, die unter dem Begriff Objektorientierung zusammengefasst werden. Als erstes wäre da Abstraktion. Das heißt, ich habe einen Satz von Daten und kümmere mich aber um die Verwaltung der Daten selber und stelle bloß einen gewissen Subset der Daten nach außen da. Ich fülle den nach außen ab, den der User halt sieht. Das heißt, ich kann... Ich habe nur eine Stelle, wo ich dafür sorgen muss, dass meine Daten konsistent sind. Das sind bei den Funktionen, die zum Objekt dazu gehören. Und von außen gibt es nur ein Interface, mit dem man das System nicht in konsistenten State bringen kann. Abstraktion. Das nächste wichtige Konzept für objektorientierte Sprachen ist Vererbung. Das heißt, ich habe ein Objekt, das macht irgendwas. Und dann kann ich sagen, ich möchte ein Objekt haben, das genau dasselbe macht, aber dass das und das und das noch mehr kann.
Oder anders.
Also als Beispiel vielleicht für ein Objekt, für ein sehr beliebtes Objekt ist halt das Auto. Und eine Spezialisierung davon ist jetzt der Sportwagen und der Lastwagen. Und in dem Fall wären also das der Lastwagen und der Sportwagen Spezialisierung von Auto und würden alle Fähigkeiten des Autos erben, die beschleunigen oder nach rechts und links lenken. Aber sie hätten eben spezielle Eigenschaften wie, dass der LKW beladen werden kann oder vielleicht ein Kipplaster wäre noch eine weitere Spezialisierung wieder von LKW, der dann eine besondere Methode hat wie Ladung abkippen, beispielsweise die beim Sportwagen nicht so vorhanden ist.
Genau, der Sportwagen würde gegenüber dem, zu seinem Vaterobjekt sozusagen, seinem Parent irgendwie einfach nur noch bestimmte Dinge einfach besser machen, beziehungsweise auch weglassen, wie zum Beispiel eine Rückbank. Also das mit der Objektorientierung ist eine sehr wichtige Sache. Das bekommt auch immer mehr Bedeutung. Also eigentlich alle neuen Programmiersprachen, die irgendwie größere Beliebtheit erfahren sind, Objektorientiert. Das hat halt viele Vorteile für den Programmierer, weil er irgendwie sein eigentliches Ziel, nämlich ein Problem zu lösen, sehr viel näher an der Realität entlangmodellieren kann. Dieses Staubsaugerbeispiel zum Beispiel, da würde ich wirklich erstmal anfangen.
Das haben wir eben nicht on air gehabt, das Staubsaugerbeispiel. Also wir haben einen Raum und den wollen wir automatisch saugen.
Ja genau, das Problem ist einfach, ich muss meine Wohnung saugen und ich möchte halt irgendwie eine Vorgabe haben, wie ich das möglichst effektiv tue, auf Basis der Länge des Stromkabels, des Staubsaugers, der verfügbaren Steckdosen in dieser Wohnung und den entsprechenden Saugradien, die ich damit erreichen kann und irgendwie, dass ich natürlich auch nicht möglichst zweimal durch ein Zimmer durchgehe und so weiter. Und das ist eine relativ komplexe Sache. Man kann es sich dadurch vereinfachen, dass man von vornherein ein objektorientiertes Modell wählt, indem man einfach erstmal die beteiligten Objekte modelliert und ihr Verhalten spezifiziert. Was kann ein Staubsauger so? Was kann irgendwie ein Raum, was für Eigenschaften hat ein Raum? Wie definiere ich die Türen, die Verbindung zwischen Räumen? Und danach fange ich an, diese Objekte zu benutzen, indem ich eine bestimmte Methodik einfüge. Das heißt, entweder haben die Objekte selber Methoden oder es gibt halt Methoden, die eben mit einem bestimmten Gruppe von Objekten bestimmte Analysen machen. Ein Programm kann sich dann alle Räume, die Eigenschaften geben lassen, sieht, was mit was verbunden ist, kann die Wege berechnen, kann dann halt irgendwie den Staubsauger mit einbeziehen. Das ist dann die eigentliche Tätigkeit des Programmierens, nämlich diese Abstraktion zunächst einmal im Kopf herzustellen. Und die besondere Gabe besteht natürlich dann daran, das auch in einen maschinenlesbaren Code über die Tastatur einzugeben, dass der Computer auch weiß, was man meint.
Also bei dem Beispiel mit den Staubsaugern ist es zum Beispiel so, dass ich für einen Hoover-Staubsauger nicht noch mal genau denselben Code hinschreibe, den ich schon für einen Siemens-Staubsauger hingeschrieben habe, sondern dass ich das, was die gemeinsam haben, nämlich da kommt irgendwie eine Strippe raus, die ich in die Steckdose stecken kann und dann kann ich damit sorgen, das schreibe ich einmal und dann mache ich zwei davon abgeleitete Klassen, nämlich den Hoover-Staubsauger und den Siemens-Staubsauger. Und nur das, was bei denen speziell ist, das muss ich da noch mal neu implementieren. Und der Code, der mit Staubsaugern arbeitet, der muss halt nur wissen, dass es Staubsauger gibt und nicht was für Staubsauger es gibt. Das bezeichnet man als Polymorphie, auch ein Feature von Programmiersprachen.
Ich finde auch die Ist-Beziehung, das Wort Ist, könnte sein jetzt immer ziemlich treffend. Ein Hoover-Staubsauger ist ein Staubsauger. Und auch ein Liele-Staubsauger ist ein Staubsauger.
Genau, und ein Staubsauger ist dann wiederum ein Elektrogerät und alle Elektrogeräte haben gemeinsam, dass sie einen Stecker nach DIN haben, den man in Steckdosen nach DIN stecken kann und dann hat das Ding Strom. Also das ist im Prinzip die Ideenwelt, in der man sich bewegt, wenn man programmiert. Und man versucht halt immer... Wenn man objektorientiert programmiert. Nee, ansonsten natürlich, es funktioniert ganz ähnlich, aber man hat halt immer gewisse Ebenen, auf denen man das Problem löst, indem man es auf andere Probleme runter bricht, die näher an der Hardware dran sind. Solange bis man irgendwo unten bei den Bits angekommen ist.
Chaosradio 52, Thema Programmiersprachen. Ja, ich will programmieren lernen und ich weiß jetzt, dass ich aus jeder der Klassen, die es da gibt, mindestens eine können sollte. Aus den objektorientierten sollte ich mir Java besorgen und das lernen. Und die prozedurale Programmiersprache, die ich lernen sollte, ist C. Und was gibt es noch?
Es gibt noch funktionale Programmiersprache. Funktionale Programmiersprachen zeichnen sich dadurch aus, dass es sozusagen keine globalen Variablen gibt. Das heißt, alle Funktionen liefern nur ein Ergebnis zurück und verändern nicht den globalen State des Programmes. Das hat gewisse Vorteile, was die Optimierung solcher Programme angeht. Man kann also die Reihenfolge, in der die Prozeduren aufgerufen werden, ist egal. Das heißt, man kann es sehr einfach parallelisieren. Man kann damit sehr einfach die Korrektheit des Programms beweisen, weil die Programmstrukturen, die da entstehen, sich relativ leicht auf eine vollständige Induktion abbilden lassen. Und es stecken auch einige interessante Konzepte drin, die man in anderen Programmiersprachen weiterverwenden kann. Also zum Beispiel, dass Funktionen selber auch Objekte sind, die ich durch die Gegend reichen kann. Dass ich also nicht nur Daten habe, mit denen ich arbeiten kann, sondern auch Funktionen, mit denen ich arbeiten kann.
Wenn du irgendwie eine Subroutine bist und du kannst generell sortieren, aber du willst bestimmte Eigenschaften von diesen Dingen, diesen Objekten, die du sortierst, möchtest du gerne wissen. Da kann ich dir halt einfach auch noch eine Funktion mit übergeben, neben den Objekten. Und diese Funktion kannst du dann benutzen für diese Objekte, um bestimmte Eigenschaften herauszubekommen.
Also Funktionen können Parameter anderer Funktionen sein. Das ist was Funktional eigentlich aussagt. Da gibt es eine ganze Reihe Sprachen, berühmt, berüchtigt. Bei den Berliner TU-Studenten ist die schöne Sprache Opal von Professor Pepper. Und im Allgemeinen verwendet wird zum Beispiel Heskel. Heskel stammte mal von Gover ab, das stammte mal von Miranda ab und wird zum Beispiel an der FU gelehrt. ML ist eine Sprache, die auch noch größerer Beliebtheit sich erfreut, weil für ML ein Compiler existiert, der guten Code erzeugt, der in Frankreich geschrieben wurde. List ist bis zum gewissen Grad auch eine funktionale Programmiersprache. Es gibt da den Lanter-Operator, mit dem man Funktionsobjekte erzeugen kann, aber in Lisp gibt es halt auch globale Bindings und Attribute, sodass es nicht wirklich die reine Lehre ist.
Die man eigentlich aber auch gar nicht haben will, die reine Lehre will man höchstens in der Lehre, aber so nicht in der Praxis oder um wirkliche Probleme damit zu lösen.
Ja, in der Praxis möchte man eigentlich eine Sprache, in der man sich das Deskonzept des Bedienen kann, das gerade am besten passt und alle zur Verfügung hat, die es so gibt. Aber um zu lernen, was es gibt, ist es manchmal ganz sinnvoll, eine reine Lehre zu studieren. Und funktionale Programmiersprachen sind schon ein bisschen exotisch. Noch ein bisschen exotischer sind regelbasierte Systeme, wie zum Beispiel Prolog oder auch Make, in denen man nur noch angibt, zum Beispiel, ja, man kann von Berlin nach Leipzig fahren und von Leipzig nach Dresden und von Dresden nach Prag. Und dann kann man sagen, fahr mal von Berlin nach Prag und der sagt dann, oh, es gibt eine Regel von da nach da, von da nach da, also kann ich mir eine zusammengesetzte Regel bauen und liefert die zurück. Und das wird in Experten-Systemen zum Beispiel eingesetzt, also Systeme, denen man sagen kann, oh, ich hab hier so eine Pflanze und die hat braune Flecken und da kriechen so Fliegen drauf rum und dann sagt er, das ist möglicherweise die und die Krankheit und geht mal das und das mit natürlich sprachiger Ein- und Ausgabe. Bei Make funktioniert es so ähnlich, das Make ist ein System, um das Kompilieren von Programmen und Zusammenbauen von Programmen zu automatisieren. Denen sage ich zum Beispiel aus einem C-File mit C-Sourcecode kann man einen Object-File erzeugen und Object-Files kann man so und so zusammenlinken. Dann sage ich nur noch, was ich als Ergebnis haben will und der ruft die richtigen Programme in der richtigen Reihenfolge auf.
Ja, damit hätten wir sie die wichtigsten Klassen eigentlich durch und können dann zu dem Thema kommen, welche Programmiersprachen man dann wirklich benutzt, um echte Probleme zu lösen.
Ja, und das klang bei diesen Funktionalen irgendwie nicht so unbedingt so, oder?
Ja, für eine eher...
Entschuldigung, regelbasiert. Was habe ich falsch geguckt?
Na, was damit zum Beispiel gemacht wird, sind automatische Beweissysteme. Das heißt, in der Mathematik läuft es heutzutage nicht mehr so, dass Leute sich hinsetzen und von Hand einen Beweis machen, sondern sie stellen Regeln auf, formulieren also mathematische Aktionen in einer Sprache, die der Computer versteht, zum Beispiel Prolog. Dann sage ich nur noch, was für eine Aussage ich bewiesen haben möchte. Und der Compiler beweist mir dann sozusagen das, was ich bewiesen haben möchte. Ich muss nur noch beweisen, dass der Beweiser richtig arbeitet, um davon auszugehen, dass der Beweis richtig ist. Zum Beispiel das Vier-Farb-Problem wurde mit diesem Prinzip gelöst.
Weißt du denn auch, in welcher Programmiersprache der...
Das Vier-Farb-Problem, wenn man Landkarten hat. Stell dir eine Landkarte vor, du möchtest jedes Land mit einer Farbe ausmalen. Und jede Druckfarbe kostet Geld. Man möchte also so wenig Farben wie möglich haben. Und es ist halt so gewesen, dass die Leute, die Landkarten machten, wussten, vier Farben reichen immer aus. Sie wussten nicht warum, aber sie wussten, es reicht. Und es wurde halt die letzten 300 Jahre nach einem Beweis dafür gesucht, dass vier Farben ausreichen. Und dieser Beweis wurde vor wenigen Jahren jetzt erbracht. Es wurden über 3000 mögliche Einzelfälle untersucht von diesem automatischen Beweissystem, um zu zeigen, dass es halt keinen Fall gibt, wo vier Farben nicht ausreichen würden.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es in Prolog geschrieben war. Ich denke, die werden das in was ordentlichem geschrieben haben. C++ beispielsweise ist genau religiöse Kriegesöffnung.
Ich hab ein Deja-vu hier. Das heißt, mit C++ kann ich mir dann, wenn ich C++ lerne, die anderen da sparen?
Naja, was heißt sparen? Es gibt wenig Probleme, für die C++ nicht geeignet wäre. So rum kann man das ausdrücken.
Es gilt sicherlich für jede Sprache.
Es gilt sicherlich, dass man im Prinzip in jeder Sprache jedes Problem, was sich mit irgendeiner anderen Programmiersprache lösen lässt, auch lösen kann. Insofern sind alle Programmiersprachen äquivalent. Aber wenn ich das Ganze jetzt unter schnell lösen möchte zum Beispiel, schnell lösen oder elegant lösen oder...
So lösen, dass das Programm, was hinterher herauskommt, schnell ist? Was ein anderer Aspekt ist, als das Problem schnell zu lösen?
Gut, jedenfalls ist da C++ die Wahl. Also es ist sicherlich das mächtigste Werkzeug unter allen Gesichtspunkten betrachtet, wo ich wirklich am meisten an Problemen mit abdecken kann und die wenigsten Kompromisse machen muss. Es ist natürlich nicht kritiklos und es ist natürlich auch ein Stück weit Ansichtssache, aber ich bin einfach davon überzeugt und...
Ja, ja, aber es gibt natürlich auch ganz offensichtliche Einschränkungen, die man sozusagen in Kauf nimmt, wenn man mit C++ arbeitet. Also besonders schön zum Beispiel sieht der Programmcode nicht aus. Also eine sehr kritische Sprache, wo man halt auch eine bestimmte Expertise sich erstmal erarbeiten muss, um das wirklich so lesen zu können wie Deutsch. Gut, es ist...
Ja, aber es geht doch nicht darum, dass es schön ist.
Natürlich, das ist ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Punkt, dass natürlich so ein Programmcode auch Ausdrucksform ist. Und ich kann praktisch dasselbe Problem auf unten... Ich meine, in der Praxis sind es schon endlich viele Arten, aber praktisch unzählbar viele verschiedene Arten lösen. Und es gibt eben Lösungen darunter, die man nach allgemeinen Kriterien, wie man sie auch in der Literatur anwenden kann, als schön, als ästhetisch, als gelungen passend bezeichnen kann. Und es gibt auch einfach Programme, die sind wirklich hässlich da. Da weigern sich die Augen dann der Zeile weiter zu folgen und der Magen fängt an zu zucken und zu stülpen.
Was genau ist es, was das auslöst?
Also diesen Ekel.
Also ich kann mir das ja kaum vorstellen, weil ich nicht programmieren kann. Vielleicht liegt es auch daran.
Es gibt ja sehr viele Programmiersprachen. Manche sind sozusagen auch explizit dafür ausgelegt, möglichst schwer lesbar zu sein.
Das sind nicht unbedingt die Programmiersprachen, mit denen die Textverarbeitungssysteme heutzutage programmiert werden, aber die gibt es halt auch.
Zum Beispiel Brainfuck. Da besteht das ganze Programm halt nur noch aus Minus, mit Plus und kleiner und größer Zeichen. So funktioniert auch ist auch eine Programmiersprache, aber sie führt einen unbedingt nicht ohne weiteres zum Ziel. Und ein gut lesbarer Code ist vor allem auch dann wichtig, wenn es nicht nur einen Programmierer gibt, der ein Programm schreibt, sondern viele Programmierer, die an einem großen System schreiben, wo vielleicht auch die Programmierer häufig wechseln, weil es eine große Firma ist, eine große Organisation, wo die Leute irgendwie sterben und alt werden und irgendwie andere kommen, die besser sind oder andere Ideen haben. Dann möchte man natürlich diesen Code auch wirklich, es muss einen Konsens geben der Lesbarkeit. Der ist bei C++, das ist sozusagen der niedrigste gemeinsame Nenner so. Das ist halt ziemlich hässlich und das ist aber auch noch sehr wichtig, aber halt nicht so hässlich, dass die Leute abhalten würden.
Also ein Kriterium für Hässlichkeit sind sicherlich sinnlose Wiederholungen. Wir hatten ja das Thema mit der Faulheit vorhin schon. Und wenn ich irgendwo fünfmal dasselbe stehen habe und jedes Mal nur mit einer ganz kleinen geringeren Änderung, dann kann ich das Ganze sicherlich, wie es so heißt, rausfakturieren. Das heißt, die jeweiligen Abweichungen erfasse ich und pack sie an eine Extrastelle. Und die Gemeinsamkeiten packe ich auch an eine Extrastelle und so vermeide ich eben Wiederholungen. Und das gelingt in C++ wirklich hervorragend, diese Wiederholungen zu vermeiden. Und der große Vorteil ist, ich kann entweder auf ganz abstrakten Niveau arbeiten oder ich kann, wenn es sein muss, auch runtersteigen und mit dem Hintern auf dem blanken Silizium herumrutschen in dieser Programmiersprache und einzelne Bits einzeln treten.
Das Problem ist, dass in C++ nicht mehr wirklich Einigkeit drüber besteht, was ein String ist. Also manche Leute verwenden den Charpointer und manche Leute verwenden den String aus der STL und wieder andere Leute verwenden G-Char. Das Problem ist, dass C++ sehr kompatibel ist und die Leute auch regen Gebrauch davon machen. Also die Bibliotheken, die es gibt, die man von C++ ansprechen kann, sind alle in verschiedenen Stilen auf den verschiedenen Abstraktionsebenen geschrieben. Und letzten Endes ist einem dieser Mix auch manchmal echt im Weg.
Das ist einerseits wahr, andererseits gibt es gibt es kaum eine Programmiersprache, die man die man so unter seinen Händen formen kann, wo man sich seine Umgebung so zurecht bauen kann, dass man sich einfach wirklich wohlfühlt.
Ja gut, aber es gibt jetzt die Programmiersprachen, wo man sich von vorne rein... C++ ist gut jetzt.
Nein, das ist ein wichtiger Aspekt.
Dein persönliches Empfinden ist, du möchtest halt gerne, als Hardcore Hacker, du möchtest halt gerne, dir alles so zusammenbauen können, dass du dich wohlfühlst. Aber andere Programmiersprachen verfolgen den Ansatz, dass es eben von sich aus schon so gebaut ist, dass man sich ohnehin schon wohlfühlt.
Lass uns das nach den Nachrichten erraten, ja? Ja 22, nee 23 Uhr und gleich 33 Minuten.
Reaktion. Die Bundesregierung will schärfer gegen Neonazis vorgehen. Bundesinnenminister Schiede kündigte in Berlin eine Beratung mit Vertretern vom Innen- Justiz- und Jugendministerium an. Brandenburgs Innenminister Schönburm forderte indessen rechtsextremistische Gewalttäter Rascha zu bestrafen. Parlamentsabstimmung. Der israelische Regierungschef Barak hat heute drei Misstrauensanträge der Opposition überstanden. Kurz nach der überraschenden Wahl des Likudkandidaten Katzow zum Staatspräsidenten erhielt der Hauptantrag des Likud keine Mehrheit. Anlauf. Am ersten Auktionstag haben die Bieter für die deutschen UMTS Mobilfunklizenzen Verhalten begonnen. Am Abend lagen die Gebote unter drei Milliarden Mark. Die Bundesregierung hofft auf einen wesentlich höheren Erlös. Preisanstieg. Ab morgen müssen die Fahrgäste im Gebiet des Verkehrsverbundes Berlin Brandenburg wieder tiefer in die Tasche greifen. Die Tickets werden um vier bis fünf Prozent teurer. Formel 1. Der Chef des Lausitzringes Fischer rechnet nicht mehr mit dem Zuschlag für den großen Preis von Deutschland. Auch nach einem Gespräch mit Formel 1 Boss Applestone sieht er keine Chancen mehr, den Lauf schon ab 2002 von Hockenheim nach Ostdeutschland zu holen.
Wetter.
Nachts 14 bis 10 Grad am Tag heiter, 23 bis 27 Grad, ein kurzes Info mit Matthias Karckow, vielen Dank.
Nicht einmal, fünfmal spielen Rosenstolz in Berlin. Es gibt nur noch Karten für den 19. Oktober und 24. und 26. November, also haltet euch ran. Genauso wie für den 6. November in der Messerhalle in Frankfurt und den 14. November in der Stadt Halle Kortbus.
Diejenigen der Hörerinnen und Hörer, die jetzt in irgendeinem Chat hängen und uns über ganz normalen Hörfunk, also Radio, hören können, können ihr mal durchsagen, dass der Real Audio Stream heute leider nicht mehr laufen wird hier auf der Fritz-Homepage. Weil... Es ist wirklich sehr schön.
Weil...
Also, der Server ist im Eimer. Und da haben wir die Firma angerufen, die für die Wartung zuständig ist, die war auch da. Haben sich das angeguckt, haben das auch gewartet, aber können es leider nicht hochfahren, weil sie das Passwort nicht haben. Das hat nämlich wiederum jemand aus der ORB EDV-Abteilung und da ist keiner erreichbar.
Ein Klassiker.
Das ist wirklich ein Klassiker. Stream heute nicht.
Aber wir haben halt nach wie vor den MP3-Stream, da müsst ihr auf den IRC-Server, IRC.CCC.de, in den Channel Chaos Radio marschieren und fragen. Und dann habt ihr den MP3-Stream.
Genau, und wenn ihr nicht wisst, was IRC ist, www.mirc.com.
Werbung für den Feind.
Einfach weiter UKW hören.
Entschuldigung, freshmiet.net und IRC eingeben.
Genau, ihr geht zu www.freshmiet.net und dann...
Ohne www.freshmiet.net.
Ihr geht zu freshmiet.net und dann gibts IRC ein.
Oh, das mach ich mal.
Ja, ihr könnt auch anrufen. Wenn ihr uns was lustiges zu erzählen habt, zum Beispiel, würden wir gerne wissen, ob ihr irgendwelche besonderen oder vielleicht seltenen Programmiersprachen benutzt, die nicht jetzt zu den aller Welts Programmiersprachen gehören, wie irgendwie C oder Pascal oder Basic oder Java oder C++, sondern halt andere besondere Sprachen, vielleicht auch aus der Klasse der funktionalen Programmiersprachen oder der objektorientierten Programmiersprachen.
Wenn du das jetzt alles nochmal ein bisschen lauter sagst, dass man es hören kann.
Ich bin schon ein bisschen im Schunkelmodus, da hast du es nicht so weit runter gedreht. Ja, dann könnt ihr anrufen und ich glaube, du hast so eine Nummerntaste, oder?
Kommt jetzt ganz schneidig rein.
Die Mikritz-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Poxter, 70 97 110.
Falls ihr irgendwelche Programmiersprachen kennt oder habt, oder in diesen Programmiersprachen je programmiert habt oder davon gehört habt, oder jemanden kennt, der solche Programmiersprachen kennt. Gucken wir mal, hier ist Chaosradio. Hallo Sotti. Sotti, Verzeihung.
Salzburg, wie hörst du uns?
Ja, übers Internet. Mittlerweile hab ich jetzt einen Stream gefunden.
Den MP3 Stream?
Super.
Das hat jetzt gedauert eineinhalb Stunden, aber jetzt geht's. Na immerhin. Seltene Programmierstrachen, genau. Ich programmier mit Delphi.
Wie selten findest du das?
Ja, nicht so besonders, aber vielleicht nicht so bekannt. Mir taugt Delphi extrem gut, weil im Vergleich zum Visual Basic zum Beispiel, mit dem man es vielleicht von der Oberfläche her vergleichen könnte, es hat viel mehr Komponenten schon dabei und die objektorientierte Programmierung und der Delphi finde ich echt super. Und darum taugt mir das wirklich. Außerdem wird von der Delphi jede Group da, während sofort alle Texte, zum Beispiel die für C++ rauskommen, für Visual C++ heißt das zum Beispiel DirectX oder irgendwas, dann wird das sofort für Delphi übersetzt und da ist man eigentlich immer up to date.
Also du findest einerseits die Sprache interessant, aber andererseits auch der Komfort, der dir von der Entwicklungsumgebung von den verfügbaren Bibliotheken bereitgestellt wird.
Und ich freue mich jetzt schon, wenn dann gegen Ende des Sommers angeblich Delphi für Linux rauskommen wird.
Delphi hat ja auch eine echt lange Geschichte. Also ich erinnere mich, die erste Version, die ich in der Hand hielt, war Turbo Pascal 3.0 auf einem CPM-System und aus Turbo Pascal wurde dann irgendwann Borland Pascal und bei der Gelegenheit haben sie dann angefangen, auch Objekte drin zu haben. Also vorher war das eine procedurale Programmiersprache, die das Niklaus Wirtmer ausgedacht hat. Und aus Borland Pascal wurde dann irgendwann Borland Delphi und dann hießen sie glaube ich Inprice zwischendurch. Jetzt gehört Coral. Und eigentlich ist es aber immer noch dasselbe. Und in der Tat eine Programmiersprache, die relativ stringent ist. Also manche Leute sagen zu sowas, Bondage in Discipline Programming Languages. Das heißt, man darf die Regel nicht brechen. Man wird also innerhalb seiner Abstraktion festgehalten, was manche Leute als Nachteil empfinden, andere Leute aber auch als Vorteil. Also zwingt einen zu besseren Stil.
Meinst du, dass zum Beispiel ich kann nicht wie in C++, wenn ich C++ programmiere, habe ich zum Beispiel Float und dann schreibe ich Doppelbo- ähm, ich schreibe nur ist gleich und dann kommt die Integer. Das kann ich in Delfinit. Hast du das gemeint in dem Sinn?
Ja, solche Geschichten. Also man wird, ein Float ist halt ein Float und du sollst dir die Bits von dem Float nicht näher angucken. Das ist eigentlich das Delfi-Konzept. Und auch kein Go-To und kein... also mittlerweile glaube ich schon. Aber in einer reinen Lehre von Niklaus Wirth gab es sowas halt alles nicht. Jo, dank dir für den Anruf.
Hallo, hier ist Fritz.
Also Delfi ist doch nicht so richtig das, was ich weite bin, besonders fremd.
Aber das haben wir nicht auf unserer Liste. Ist aber auch ganz okay, wenn man...
Das gibt es halt unter Windows.
Ist halt unter Windows, ist eine Commerzsoftware. Aber dafür ist es eigentlich relativ gut.
Guten Abend. Also, ich bevorzuge ja Java. Weil ich denke, dass Java viele Komponenten verbindet. Einmal, das ist die ganze Sache mit Windows, das da kompatibel ist. Dann die ganze Sache mit Vererbung. Ich meine, das hat man bei C++ auch schon. Aber ich denke, Java ist, ich würde sagen, eine Erweitung von C++.
Das ist wahr und falsch. Also, es gibt ein paar Features mehr in Java als C++. Es gibt zum Beispiel Garbage Collection. Das war die Geschichte mit dem Speicher wieder freigeben. Das muss man nicht selber machen. Aber es gibt jede Menge Object-oriented Features, die Java einfach nicht hat. Es gibt zum Beispiel keine Mehrfachvererbung. Es gibt nur Interfaces, was ein bisschen was anderes ist. Es gibt keine Templates, die man in C++ eigentlich dann doch braucht, um sinnvoll programmieren zu können und in Java fehlen zu können.
In Java gerne hätte. Insbesondere Java, da stecken viele schöne Sachen drin. Was allerdings, wenn man C++ gewohnt ist, vermisst man doch das eine oder andere Feature. Aber mal eine Frage, was machst du so mit Java? Wozu setzt du das ein?
Ich habe damit angefangen in der Schule zu programmieren. Ich habe eine ganze Weile Internet-Sachen programmiert, die man auf Webpages mit einbinden kann. Und dann sinnlose Programme. Für den Hausgebrauch. Hacks. Weiß ich.
Kennst du noch eine andere Programmersprache?
Ich möchte nicht sagen, dass ich perfekt kann. Ich denke, man kann eigentlich keine Programmersprache perfekt, aber ich kann sehr gut Turbo. Aber das nur von der Schule. Insofern ist es ziemlich veraltet, und viele Leute sagen, dass Turbo insofern eine totale Kack-Programmersprache ist.
Du meinst Turbo Pascal, oder? Aber es gab auch ein Turbo C.
Ach, echt? Oh, tut mir leid. Macht nichts. Also ich hab's halt von der Schule, und ich mein ja, ich find's nicht schlecht. Damit kann man auch viele Sachen machen, aber es ist halt nicht mehr der Standard von heute, aber es ist trotzdem so.
Wenn du das kannst, bist du eigentlich schon ziemlich nahe an Delphi dran. Also die Unterschiede sind da nicht besonders groß. Insofern schadet es auch nicht, wenn du das kannst. Viele Sprachen sind ja echt alt. Also Lesben stammt aus Anfang der 60er, C ist seit Anfang der 70er unter uns. Und die Konzepte ändern sich eigentlich nicht so in Jahresschritten oder in der Monatsgeschwindigkeit, die man momentan aus dem Internet in den Hardwaresektor kommt, sondern so eher in Jahrzehnten passiert das.
Ich muss sagen, ganz früh angefangen habe ich ja sowieso mit Basics. Ich meine, da bin ich nicht enttäuscht, ich bin dann relativ schnell auf Tone, Passtale umgestiegen. Und was ich jetzt aber noch sagen wollte, ich habe von so über die Schönheit von diesen Quelltexten geredet.
Allerdings, es gibt nur wenige Sprachen, in denen man echt schönen Code produzieren kann. Aber hässlichen Code kann man in jeder Sprache produzieren, finde ich. Also es kommt nicht nur auf die Sprache an, sondern auch auf die Art und Weise, wie du das hinschreibst. Ob du jetzt alles am Anfang der Zeit schreibst, oder ob du schön einrückst usw. Das ist auch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt.
Ich denke mal, das ist sowieso bei dem Programmierer, du musst dich überlassen, was er draus macht. Also man kann einen relativ schönen Freitext und werfen. Man kann aber genau denselben Effekt rauskriegen und einen total herrschlichen Freitext haben.
Genau. Zu dem Thema gibt es auch einen Wettbewerb. Und zwar den International Obfuscated C Code Contest. Mittlerweile gibt es das auch für andere Programmiersprachen. Da geht es gerade darum, möglichst unverständliche Programme zu schreiben, die in möglichst wenig Code möglichst interessante Dinge tun. Also das ist dann keine Art und Weise mehr, wie man in der Praxis programmiert und Probleme zu lösen, sondern das hat eher so einen künstlerischen Anspruch.
Ja, und da fällt mir gerade ein, wir haben ja auch noch kein Wort zu interkeil verloren. Also das ist sicherlich auch eine Programmiersprache, eine der hässlichsten oder schwierigsten Programmiersprachen, die genau mit dem Ziel eigentlich gestaltet wurde, Programmieren möglichst unmöglich zu machen. Also das ist vielleicht ein Tipp, wenn man mal das andere Spektrum sich anschauen will, was so möglich ist.
Ich schaue noch nicht so lang zu, aber habt ihr schon über diese hässliche Programmiersprache mit Plus, Minus und so geredet?
Also interkeil ist fast noch heftiger, also müsst ihr vorstellen, bei interkeil...
Heftiger? Ich hab's ja gesehen.
Ja, aber bei interkeil sind also wesentliche Features, also mindestens 30, maximal 50% der Zeilen müssen mit Please anfangen. Sonst weigert der Compiler... Please do. Sonst weigert der Compiler, sich was zu tun. Dann gibt es kein Go To, sondern das wurde durch Come From ersetzt. Und außerdem gibt es noch ein paar andere, nicht jugendfreie Details. Es gibt im Wesentlichen genau zwei Operatoren. Es gibt eine Anweisung, die heißt Forget zum Beispiel. Da wird dann die Zeile nur einmal ausgeführt. Und wenn man das nächste Mal vorbeikommt, dann wird diese einfach ausgelassen beispielsweise. Oder wie war das noch?
Kannst du die noch mal kurz erläutern?
Ja, die Operatoren, also es gibt keinen Plus und Minus, sondern es gibt Select und Intermingle. Bei Intermingle ist es so, du gibst ihm zwei Parameter und der nimmt dann von dem einen einen Bit und dann von dem anderen einen Bit und dann von dem anderen und von dem anderen immer abwechselnd. Und Select funktioniert so, dass da, wo in dem ersten Parameter die Bits gesetzt sind, aus dem zweiten Dippel rausgenommen werden, dann werden sie nach rechts zusammengeschoben. Und sonst gibt es nichts in dieser Software.
Das dient ja für Schlüsselung, oder?
Das dient, wie gesagt, dem Zweck, Programmieren möglichst schwierig zu machen. Also eine für Adwettungsentwicklung nicht wirklich zu entdecken. Aber es gibt einen kompletten Compiler und...
Reden Sie über eine Programmiersprache? So ein Kryptoprogramm.
Nein, eine ist eine Programmiersprache, heißt Intercal. Und es gibt einen Compiler dafür, mehrere sogar von mehreren Leuten geschrieben und einiges auch an Software, die man im Web finden kann, die in Intercal geschrieben ist.
Intercal, na, wirft doch einfach mal deine Lieblingssuchmaschine an.
Und?
Und suche nach Intercal. Also es gibt, die URL ist ein bisschen zu kompliziert. Ihr könnt einfach mal danach suchen. Es gibt eine schöne Webseite im Web, die heißt 99 Bottles of Beer. Kann man sozusagen darüber ganz gut finden. Es geht um Programmiersprachen und dort ist aufbauend auf einem Ereignis in einer Newsgroup, da hat jemand mal dieses 99 Bottles of Beer on the wall, dann schmeißen sie mal Flaschen gegen die Wand und dann ist eine weniger und dann singen sie wieder das gleiche, so ein amerikanischer, weiß nicht. Englischer glaube ich. Und irgendwie, man hat das einfach mal alle Zeilen, die man hat sozusagen zu singen, halt in die Newsgroup gepostet. Und dann kam schon der erste Programmierer hinterher und meinte, aber das kann man ja irgendwie auch in Basic machen mit einer Schleife und hat dann irgendwie das Programm, sozusagen ein Basic Programm gepostet, dessen Ausgabe der Text dieses Liedes ist. Und dann kam halt ein Programmierer nach dem anderen mit seiner Lieblingsprogrammiersprache und hat seine Variante in den Topf geworfen. Auf dieser Webseite 99 Bottles of Beer findet man alle bisher gefundenen Lösungen. Es sind mittlerweile weit über 200 Programmiersprachen, in denen dieses recht simple Problem auf ganz unterschiedliche Art und Weise angegangen wurde. Eine davon ist auch Interkeil, da kannst du das dann gleich mal angucken. Danach hast du wahrscheinlich auch dem Compiler kein großes Interesse mehr.
Ich wünsche mir nun schon mehr Amts.
Gleichfalls. Hallo, Robert.
Ja, ich wollte vielleicht noch eine Außenseite anführen, der vielleicht ein Grenzfall ist, vielleicht nicht die Programmiersprache ist, aber ich denke es ist vielleicht was Ähnliches. Das ist ein Night Tracer, bei dem man die Szenen in einen Quellkurs beschreibt und weil da auch so, Bier heißt das, dass sich das selbst aufruft und alles Mögliche funktioniert, denke ich vielleicht auch eine Programmiersprache.
Definitiv eine Programmiersprache. Das 99 Bottles of Bier Problem ist unter anderem auch in Koffrey gelöst worden, wo er irgendwie den Text gleich auf eine 3D-Kugel raufmappt und irgendwie einen Lichtpunkt setzt und dann hat man das gleiche auch in 3D.
Also es ist ein Grenzfall deswegen, weil es ja einiges an Datenbeschreibungssprachen gibt, die keine Programmiersprachen sind. Also das Beispiel HTML hatten wir ja schon. Und eigentlich, es gibt mehrere so Raytracer Grafikbearbeitungsprogramme, Inputbeschreibungssprachen. Und einige davon sind halt keine Programmiersprachen, weil sie keine Schleifenkonstrukte erlauben, keine Tests erlauben, keine Arithmetik erlauben und so weiter. Aber Pofrey ist in der Tat einer.
Ja, für Interessierte kann ich vielleicht noch die URL einmal Pofreyorg und IRTCorg eingehen, so dass man sich mal ein paar Sachen angucken kann.
Also ich selber hab schon was gemacht mit Quick Basic hier von das. Und hatte mal ne Frage, man sieht ja immer so in irgendwelchen Zeitungen, C plus Fluss, wie man das lernt in der Package, ist aber nicht zu C. Ich wollte euch mal fragen, ob ihr mir sagen könnt, wo ich das herbekomme.
Na, was für ein Betriebssystem hast du denn? Ja, da gibt's ja auch irgendwie entsprechende C-Compiler dafür, die du ja irgendwie im Netz organisieren kannst. Das Beste ist natürlich, du gehst auf Open Source. Dann holst du hier den GCC-Compiler. Den findest du einfach mal überall. Gute Anlaufstelle für alle Arten von Programmen und alles, was mit programmieren zu tun hat, ist auch dieses freshmeet.org. Entschuldigung, freshmeet.net. Oder halt auch andere Suchmaschinen oder Directories.
Also was du wahrscheinlich haben willst, ist das Zykwin32-Environment. Wenn die nächstgelegene Suchmaschine eintippen. Das ist ein Port von GCC und verschiedenen anderen Programmen, die man braucht, um mit C zu arbeiten auf die Windows-Umgebung. Kommt original aus dem GNU-Projekt. Also auch die Compiler, die unter Linux verwendet werden, mit denen Linux gemacht wurde. Die wurden halt von einer Firma namens Zykonus auf Windows portiert.
Dann hab ich noch eine Frage.
Die ist kostenlos, ja.
Wie kann ich die herbekommen?
Alles im Netz.
Also einfach nach Pölz?
Geisterstunde, die Musik, die hier aufgelegt wird, wird tatsächlich aufgelegt von einem Menschen und zwar Dr. Bietnick aus Hamburg und ihr hört das Chaosradio Nummer 52 und das Oberthema, der Oberbegriff, der kommt jetzt hier vom Band. Und unser Thema sind die Programmiersprachen. Was für eine Frage hatten wir noch mal an die Hörer. In was für seltsamen Sprachen programmiert ihr denn bitteschön und vor allen Dingen was?
Fragen wir mal.
Das ist Chaosradio. Danke.
Der programmiert den TV-TV.
Chaosradio hier ist nach.
Ja, ich hab gerade noch was nettes gefunden und zwar nennt sich das wohl eine Weiterentwicklung von Java, Java 2K und das hat eine sehr interessante Eigenschaft und zwar nennt sich das Ding nicht deterministisch und jede Funktion hat nur eine Wahrscheinlichkeit von 10%, dass sie erfolgreich ausgeführt wird.
Was heißt das?
Hast du irgendeine URL vielleicht?
Ja, Moment, die ist aber hammer kompliziert.
Mail so uns Chaosradio at fritz.de Schick mal, das ist nach der Arbeit 2K in der nächsten Sichtmaschinerie.
Was ich gerade auch gelesen hab, was auch noch nett ist, Garbage Collection hat das Ding natürlich auch und das macht den Speicher ganz am Ende frei oder halt in zufälligen Intervallen. Also genau so wie man es haben will eigentlich.
Manchmal.
Worauf ich aber eigentlich hinaus wollte, ich hab da noch was anderes nettes gefunden. Und zwar, man sollte sich ja manchmal auch ein bisschen Gedanken um Sicherheit machen oder so. Und da gibt es wohl ein Projekt, das nennt sich www.erosos.org. Das steht für Extrem Reliable Operating System. Und die basteln auch auf objektorientierten Strukturen, was das so gestrickt ist, dass jedes Objekt nur die Ressourcen zugreifen kann darf, wofür es auch wirklich eine Referenz gekriegt hat. Das klingt extrem interessant, weil man sich so wirklich vor allen Sachen schützen kann. Und nachher muss man sich vielleicht auch mal angucken.
Das ist nicht wirklich eine Programmiersprache, aber ist in der Tat eines der interessantesten Betriebssystemprojekte, das ich gesehen habe in letzter Zeit.
Ja, genau, das war der Ansatz. Da gibt es ja auch eine Mailingliste und da wird auch unter anderem über eine Weiterentwicklung, ist nicht das richtige Wort, eine Klassenbibliothek für Java diskutiert, worauf man das dann in die Anwendung schützen könnte. Vielleicht sollte man für solche Sachen ein bisschen mehr Werbung machen, weil vielleicht könnte sowas die Welt ein bisschen besser machen.
Denke ich auch.
Das wollen wir noch alle.
Schöner ist es nicht zu sagen.
Es gibt über uns in der Tat eine ernsthafte Anwendung von probabilistischen Programmiersprachen. Und zwar in dem, was mittlerweile von der KI übrig geblieben sind, so mutierende Algorithmen. Also Programme, die sich selbst replizieren, sich woanders hin in Speicher kopieren und dann dort einen Tochterprozess erzeugen, sich dahin forken. Und es ist halt so, dass die Lebenszeit dieser Programme begrenzt ist. Und es ist so, dass zufällige Mutationen auftreten können. Das heißt, bestimmte Instruktionen werden nicht ausgeführt, zweimal ausgeführt und so weiter und so fort, so dass die Programme sich im Laufe der Zeit auch verändern. Und dadurch, dass sie irgendwann sterben, ist es so, dass nur die überleben, die sich möglichst effizient kopieren. Und es gab da ein Projekt, das hat angefangen, da hat jemand von Hand eine solche Prozedur geschrieben. Und die hat dann tatsächlich angefangen zu mutieren. Es sind erst größere Versionen entstanden. Dann sind daraus Versionen entstanden, die kleiner waren als das Original. Bestimmte sind dann wieder ausgestorben. Dann haben sich virale Formen entwickelt, die also den Programmcode von anderen Instanzen mitbenutzt haben und so weiter und so fort. Und also im Prinzip ein bisschen Evolutionstheorie.
Erinnert mich so ein bisschen auch an Core Wars. Ich weiß nicht, ob sich da noch jemand von euch dran erinnert.
Ja, ich nicht.
Core Wars war ein ganz einfaches System, wo man so eine geschlossene virtuelle Maschine hat mit irgendwie definierten Instruktionen. Und man teilte sich sozusagen diesen Speicher mit einem anderen Programm. Und diese beiden Programme liefen halt gleichzeitig. Und Ziel war es nun, diesen Speicherraum für sein Programm sozusagen nutzbar zu machen, das andere Programm auszuschalten.
Also als Brettspiel heißt es Reverse, oder?
Ja, vielleicht eher Geräusche.
Also Programme, die eben in einer Arena direkt gegeneinander kämpfen, die versuchen, sich gegenseitig zu überschreiben und zu zerstören, beziehungsweise den anderen Thread auch mit einer Kopie des eigenen zu infizieren. Ja, dazu zu bringen, auch eine Kopie des eigenen Programms auszuführen. Und da gab es regelrecht Weltmeisterschaften, wo halt Programme gegeneinander angetreten sind, ganz brutal in Maschinenform allerdings und wo ja...
Gladiatorspielchen für Chips.
Das hat auch was.
Ja, ich meine, es ist spielerisch, aber es steckt halt auch wieder ein interessanter Ansatz drin. Es gibt halt ein Ziel, aber es gibt eben sehr viele verschiedene Strategien, wie man dieses Ziel erreichen kann. Da hat man jetzt eine defensive Taktik und versucht auszuweichen, sich möglich diffus durch den Speicher zu verbreiten, dass man das andere Programm eigentlich finden kann. Oder geht man einfach rabiat vor und versucht alles niederzuknallen, aber da beide Programme sozusagen gleichzeitig laufen, entscheidet sich sozusagen, wer damit seine Strategie am schnellsten hat.
Kurze, kleine Programme waren halt schwieriger zu treffen, während große Programme, die mit vielen Kopien arbeiteten, eben robuster gewesen sind. Auf jeden Fall eine sehr interessante, theoretische Geschichte.
Mir klingelt das Telefon, ich geh nochmal ran. Hier ist Chaosradio, hallo.
Den hatten wir schon.
Den hatten wir schon. Hat immer noch nichts dazu gelernt.
Das ist die TMF-Programmierer.
Hallo Klopster.
Nö, nicht so direkt.
Nicht immer. Schade, unser Thema sind nämlich Programmiersprachen. Und die Frage war, in was für Sprachen programmiert ihr denn eigentlich so? Und vor allem, was für Seltenen. Hier ist Chaosradio.
Ja, also ich programmiere mehrere Programmiersprachen. Teilweise sind sie halt nicht so selten. Teilweise sind sie halt wieder ein bisschen seltener. Zum Beispiel Texte verlegen, ist halt toll. Richtig nett für Netzseiten bauen, ist PHP meine Lieblingssprache. Betriebssystem fernsteuern, mach ich mit 6.
Das heißt, du bist Amiga-Benutzer?
Nee, nicht ganz.
Ja, und was ist deine Lieblingsprogrammiersprache?
Ich habe die Theorie, dass man am besten mehrere Programmiersprachen nehmen sollte und dann jeweils für das Problem, das man gerade hat, die best rauspicken sollte. Anstatt sich auf einen zu stürzen, damit zu versuchen, alles zu erschlagen.
Auf welchem Level programmierst du unter OS2?
Auf welchem Level? Also Ring 3?
Benutzt du, machst du eher Anwendungen, die direkt auf den Kernel aufsetzen oder eher Anwendungen in der User Interface?
Ja, also ich hab mich bisher nur an Ring 3 dran getraut, also User Sachen.
Ich meine nicht, ob du Kernelcode programmierst, sondern ob du diese objektorientierten Programmierer unterstützenden Features von OS2 benutzt. Workplace Shell und? Workplace Shell und vor allem dieses Somm, das System Object Model. OS2 war ja eines der ersten Betriebssysteme, was sozusagen diese Objektorientierungsidee für Programmiersprachen auch in Teilen ins Betriebssystem mit integriert hat, sodass man eben zwischen einzelnen Programmen, die auch in völlig unterschiedlichen Programmiersprachen geschrieben sein könnten, Code aufrufen kann, sodass die Programme sich untereinander aufrufen, dass sie sozusagen der Programmierer Kontext über ein Programm hinausgeht und Programme sich miteinander unterhalten. Das war bei OS2 halt gut drin.
Ja, so die Sommensachen, dann hab ich mich auch noch nicht gewagt. Das war wohl ziemlich kompliziert, da irgendwie Systemerhaltungen zu schreiben. Weil wenn man da einen kleinen Fehler macht, dann kann man gleich ziemlich viel zerhaken. Wenn man sich zum Beispiel den Netscape anguckt unter OS2, wenn der mal wieder meint, kann man das System lahmlegen zu müssen, dann kann man halt wirklich nichts machen, außer warten, bis es weitergeht.
Wobei der Netscape unter OS2 zu den stabilsten Netscapes überhaupt gehört. Da hat IBM mich noch mal hinterher angefasst und ein paar Fehler draus beseitigt.
Ja, das ist schlimm genug eigentlich.
Ja, bei Mac OS ist es noch viel, viel schlimmer.
Ja, mit Mac hab ich auch so meine Erfahrungen, dass der immer hängen bleibt.
Gibt's Sprachen, die du noch unbedingt lernen willst?
Ja, Python würd ich mir gerne mal angucken. Ja, das ist eigentlich so das nächste, was ich gerne lernen würde.
Wir haben noch eine Empfehlung für dich später in der Sendung.
Echt? Hör aufmerksam zu. Und danke für deinen Anruf. Ich muss jetzt gerade mal musikalisch hier ein bisschen unterbrecherisch wirksam werden, weil wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit von Dr. Bietnick aus Hamburg gehört, was er auflegt. Und was wir jetzt bis zum Schluss der Sendung hören, sind alles Sachen, die Dr. Bietnick selbst gemacht hat und natürlich auch auflegt. Chaosradio 52, 0 und 12 Minuten. Die Musik kommt gerade von Dr. Bietnick aus Hamburg, selbst produziert. Dark Western heißt das Stück, was wir da gerade hören und 12 Minuten nach 0 Uhr haben wir's. Ihr redet also nicht nur ihr, sondern ich mach ja manchmal mit. Also so am Rande reden wir über Programmiersprachen. Jetzt, ihr sagt immer, ja es gibt seit ein 60er Jahr, gibt seit ein 40er Jahr. Also mein PC läuft noch mit einer Lochkarte von Zuse und so was.
Hatte der schon Lochkarten?
Damals hatten wir keine Einsen und Nullen, damals hatten wir nur Nullen.
Hey, nicht schlecht.
War ja auch kurz nach dem Krieg.
Einsen wurden erst später erfunden.
Gibt's denn da irgendwie auch was Neues? Oder arbeiten tatsächlich nicht alle auf irgendwie 40 Jahre alten Sachen? Also niemand fährt ein 40 Jahre altes Auto außer er hat Geld.
Ja, aber jeder fährt ein Auto, was dessen Konzept irgendwie vor 40 Jahren schon so mehr oder minder existiert hat.
Okay, es gibt natürlich einige aktuelle Entwicklungen auf dem Sprachensektor. Also die Sprachen, die derzeit aktuell eingesetzt werden. Gut, Java ist ein gegenläufiger Trend. Java ist erst fünf Jahre alt, aber Java enthält kein Konzept, das nicht schon 20 Jahre alt wäre. Der Fortschritt in den Programmiersprachen ist immer mit dem Fortschritt in der Compiler-Technik verbunden. Das heißt, wirklich erfolgreich sind Sprachen, die sich auch effizient kompilieren lassen. Beispiel C++, das vom Feature-Umfang sicherlich nicht optimal ist, aber das sich auf jeden Fall in effizienten Code umsetzen lässt und deshalb sehr, sehr erfolgreich ist. Und diese Compiler-Technologie ist nicht stehen geblieben. Die Compiler werden immer besser, die Optimizer werden immer besser. Und einige Features sind dazugekommen, zum Beispiel Multiple Dispatch ist ein Feature, das in C++ zum Beispiel nicht enthalten ist. Da ist es so, dass es immer ein Objekt gibt, auf dem ich eine Methode aufrufe. Das heißt, dessen Klasse ich mir angucke und deswegen entscheide, welche der Funktionen, die genauso heißen, aufzurufen ist. Und Multiple Dispatch ist halt so, dass zur Laufzeit er sich mehrere Objekte anguckt. Also ein simples Beispiel A plus B kann ich in C++ nicht so programmieren, dass er sich sowohl den Typ von A als auch den Typ von B zur Laufzeit anguckt. Mindestens eins von beiden, nämlich A oder B, muss zur Compile-Zeit bekannt sein. Und das schränkt den Programmierer in seiner Freiheit natürlich ein. Er kann nicht ganz so dynamisch programmieren, wie das möglich wäre, wenn sowohl A als auch B frei wählbar wäre.
Wenn ich das mal übersetzen darf. Stell dir einfach vor, du hast ein Programm geschrieben und dieses Programm enthält eine Funktion und diese Funktion heißt Make Sex. Was diese Funktion im Detail tut, spielt zunächst einmal keine Rolle, sondern man möchte es einfach irgendwann einmal einleiten und dann übergibt man ihm Parameter, die sozusagen die Art und Weise, wie er diesen Sex durchführt, maßgeblich bestimmen. Das sind dann zum Beispiel die Teilnehmer. Wenn ich jetzt also in einem Programm schreibe, Make Sex, Klammer auf, Peter, Mary, Klammer zu, Semikolon, dann muss halt Sex gemacht werden zwischen Peter und Mary. In den Programmiersprachen, die über Multiple Dispatch nicht verfügen, sondern die mit Single Dispatch arbeiten, ist Peter sozusagen das Objekt, an dem sich alles orientiert. Und die Methode, die aufgerufen wird, gehört sozusagen Peter oder wird von Peter bereitgestellt. Nun hat das natürlich mit Real World Terms herzlich wenig zu tun, weil uns ist natürlich völlig klar, dass Mary da einfach mal kräftig was zu sagen hat in der ganzen Geschichte. Das Problem ist also, dass man die Funktion, die aufgerufen wird, eigentlich auf Basis aller Parameter auswählen möchte. Es gibt halt verschiedene Arten und Weisen Sex zu machen. Und in diesem Fall möchte man halt gerne diese Art Sex durchführen, die stattfindet, wenn Peter auf Mary trifft. Wobei Mary, Peter sozusagen genau das gleiche Ergebnis erzielt, was aber bei einer Single Dispatch Sprache einfach nicht der Fall ist. Und das ist einfach wie die Welt funktioniert. Und wenn eine Poemiersprache so funktioniert, wie die Welt funktioniert, ist man halt an der Welt etwas näher dran.
Chaosradio 52. Unser Thema sind die Programmiersprachen. Die Musik, die kommt von Dr. Bietnick aus Hamburg. Und das, was wir jetzt hier hören, das ist unter seinem Projektnamen Flow erschienen. Das kann man sich sogar holen. Also das meiste, was wir hier hören, ist unveröffentlicht. Was jetzt läuft, kann man sich kaufen. Der Projektname ist Flow und erschienen ist das Ganze bei, ich kann meine eigene Schrift nicht lesen, Silence Records. Erschienen ist es bei Silence Records. Flow oder auch Dr. Bietnick aus Hamburg.
Hast du nicht auch mp3s auf Bisonic liegen? Was?
Lass uns über Programmiersprachen reden. Also wie war das jetzt, wenn ich beim Sex unten liegen will?
Du möchtest sozusagen eine Programmiersprache haben, die dein Wohlgefühl sicherstellt.
Genau, die Programmiersprache nennt sich Dyln. Dyln ist eine Entwicklung, die Apple mal angefangen hat für den Newton. Also sie wollten eine Programmiersprache für den Newton entwickeln. Das sollte halt der perfekte Computer werden. Und dafür musste man halt einfach auch eine eigene Programmiersprache entwickeln. Sind damit nicht ganz fertig geworden. Auf den Newton gab es dann Newton's Script. Aber die Dyln Entwicklung ist weitergegangen. Basierte ursprünglich mal auf Lisp und sah auch Lisp ähnlich aus. Hat mittlerweile eher eine Pascal-ähnliche Syntax. Apple hat das Projekt irgendwann fallen lassen, zusammen mit ein paar anderen coolen Projekten. Aber es gibt eine kommerzielle Implementation von einer Firma namens Functional Objects. Und es gibt eine freie Implementation, die an der Carnegie Mellon Universität entwickelt wurde und die jetzt als Clue Projekt weiter gepflegt wurde. Das Besondere an Dyln ist halt, dass es die Features, die man von sehr dynamischen Programmiersprachen kennt, also einen sehr hohen Abtraktionslevel und eine sehr hohes Maßentweblichkeit mit effizienter Kompilierung verbindet. Und dass das Programmieren sicherer, einfacher und bequemer macht, ohne dass man dafür einen Preis in der Geschwindigkeit zahlen muss, wie bei anderen dynamischen Sprachen. Python viel vorhin. Python ist vom Feature-Umfang her fast dasselbe, aber kann halt nicht kompiliert werden, läuft 20-mal so langsam.
Was heißt denn genau dynamische Programmiersprache?
Also das ist ein Wort, das irgendwie mehrfach überladen ist. Also es gibt mehrere Bedeutungen davon. Es gibt dynamisches Binding zum Beispiel. Also wenn ich einer Variabel in einen Namen gebe in meiner Programmiersprache, ist das dann immer dieselbe Stelle im Speicher oder kann sich das ändern, je nachdem wo das herkommt? Ein anderes dynamisches Feature ist, dass man am laufenden Programm entwickeln kann. Das ist also eine Geschichte, die man bei Smalltalk hat, dass man nicht Sauce-Code hat, den man übersetzt und dann startet, sondern das Programm läuft die ganze Zeit vor sich hin und man fügt neuen Code hinzu und irgendwann speichert man den Laufzustand des Programmes ab und das ist dann das Programm, das man ausliefert. Das macht Tests sehr viel einfacher. Man kann einfach das laufende Programm mal kurz die Funktion aufrufen, die man gerade geschrieben hat. Das macht halt auch die Fehlersuche einfacher. Das heißt, wenn ein Fehler auftritt, stürzt das Programm nicht ab, sondern es kommt ein Fenster hoch und sagt, es ist gerade ein Fehler aufgetreten. Dann kann man als Programmierer den Fehler beheben, den geänderten Sourcecode ins Programm tun und das Programm dann einfach an der Stelle weiterlaufen lassen, ohne noch mal auf diese Fehlerbedingungen zu warten.
Man zahlt natürlich für all diese Dinge einen Preis, den man unter Umständen nicht bereit ist zu bezahlen. An sich sieht es in der Theorie alles ganz schick aus, aber am Ende fehlt mir zumindest dieses Stück Kontrolle. Und das ist für mich beispielsweise der Grund, warum.
Was möchtest du denn kontrollieren?
Naja, keine Programmiersprache, kein Compiler, keine Umgebung ist auch nur halbwegs fehlerfrei. Und deswegen ist es notwendig, diese Fehler, die überall drin sind, kompensieren oder umgehen zu können. Und wenn ich dagegen mich in einer Programmiersprache ausdrücken muss, die zu viel alleine macht, die meint, besser zu wissen, was gut ist für mich, als dass ich es selber weiß, mich bevormundet.
Mutti, du hast Angst, Dave.
Ich mag einfach nicht Kinderansicherung und Systeme.
Aber das ist ja nicht der Fall bei Dürren. Ich meine, worin besteht diese Bevormundung? Dein Argument ist wahrscheinlich, du kannst nicht auf einzelne Bits in einem Beid irgendwie problemlos zugreifen und weißt nicht sicher, dass das jetzt genau das Register ist. Aber in 99, 9 Prozent der Fälle, in denen du halt eine Anwendung programmierst, benötigst du eine solche Funktionalität nicht. Das heißt, dafür, dass du das hast, kaufst du das teuer ein, weil deine Programmiersprache zum Beispiel nicht irgendwie zur Laufzeit Namen binden kann. Oder Garbage-Connection macht man. Was einfach etwas ist, was man ohnehin tun muss. Und wenn ein Subsystem das effizient genug tut, dann ist es schön.
Ich glaube einfach nicht, dass ich nicht bei Dylen beispielsweise für Dinge auch bezahlen muss, die ich gar nicht verwende oder brauche in dem Moment. Oder eigentlich nur für das zahlen, was ich benutze und nicht für das, was ich benutzen könnte.
Also Pay As You Go war eigentlich die Design-Philosophie von Dylen. Das heißt, man bezahlt nur für die Features, die man tatsächlich auch benutzt, um vielleicht mal ein paar Zahlen zu nennen. Der aktuelle Dylen-Compiler getestet gegen einige andere Programmiersprachen. Aufgabe war siebtes Eratostinus implementieren. Für die erste Profilion. Integer. Siebtes Eratostinus, ein sehr alter Algorithmus zur Bestimmung von Primzahlen. Funktioniert so, du fängst an mit einer Liste aller Zahlen und die erste Zahl, auf die du stößt, ist zum Beispiel die 2. Die 2 hast du vorher noch nicht gesehen, ist kein Häkchen dran, also ist eine Primzahl. Jetzt machst du aber bei allen Vielfachen von 2 ein Häkchen, bei 6, bei 8, bei 10, bei 12, gehst weiter durch die Liste durch, stößt auf die 3. An der 3 ist noch kein Häkchen, also machst du an alle Vielfachen von 3 ein Häkchen und 3 ist eine Primzahl. 4, stellst du fest, ist ein Häkchen dran, bist du schon vorbeigekommen, als du die 2 bearbeitet hast. 5, noch kein Häkchen und so weiter und so fort. So kommen alle Primzahlen zustande. Das in C implementiert, hatte eine Laufzeit von 3, 9 Sekunden. Auf derselben Maschine in Düln, ohne Bounce Checking, 4, 76 Sekunden, mit Bounce Checking 4, 77 Sekunden. Das heißt, ein Sprachfeature, was C nicht hat, ein C++, was man aber gerne haben möchte, nämlich Bounce Checking, und zwar immer unter allen Umständen, kostet dich weniger als 0, 1 Prozent in der Rechenleistung.
Bounce Checking ist was bitte?
Um zu prüfen, ob ein Wert bei einem Zugriff sich innerhalb eines zulässigen Wertebereichs befindet. Das heißt, es ist sozusagen so was wie ein Netz beim Turnen. Aber manchmal habe ich halt keine Zeit oder möchte tatsächlich dieses Netz einfach nicht haben. Das gilt bei Grafik-Algorithmen oder wenn ich mich gerne irgendwie durch den Speicher fräse oder andere Echtzeitanforderungen habe, dann möchte ich einfach gerne dieses Bonds-Checking einfach nicht haben.
Wenn es dich 0, 1% kostet und du dafür garantiert hast, dass dein Programm nicht einfach abstürzt mit einem Fehler, den du nicht so einfach findest, sondern dir präzise sagt, an welcher Stelle welcher Fehler aufgetreten ist, finde ich das eigentlich einen Preis, den ich bereit bin zu zahlen.
Du gewinnst eine ganze Komfort und ich kann nur noch mal sagen, ein Programm, was irgendwie vielleicht die Hälfte der Zeit braucht, als ein anderes Programm, aber dafür sechs Monate später fertig wird, ist einfach langsamer.
Und gerade bei Bounce-Checking ist es so, dass die Vorstellung, dass Bounce-Checking langsam ist, aus Zeiten kommt, als es noch keine superskalaren CPUs gab, wo also wirklich jeder Befehl gekostet hat. Aber die modernen superskalaren CPUs können mehrere Instruktionen gleichzeitig bearbeiten. Und gerade Bounce-Checking ist eine Geschichte, die sich auf aktuellen CPUs sehr gut parallelisieren kann. Das heißt, der zusätzliche Aufwand wird von Hardware erledigt, die normalerweise sowieso nicht benutzt wird.
Das ist immer noch das Chaosradio 52 zum Thema Kupier. Ich bin daneben. Programmiersprachen. Irgendwas ist mit meinen Wortfindungsstörungen. Die Musik, die ist produziert worden von Dr. Beatnik im DJS Hamburg und der veröffentlicht diese Musik auch und zwar unter dem Namen Flow. Im Netz könnt ihr das euch anhören, runterladen. www.bisonic.com und da einfach mal suchen nach einem Menschen, der sich da Flow nennt. 033 dann nennen.
Reaktionen. Die Bundesregierung will Schärfer gegen Neonazis vorgehen. Bundesinnenminister Schiele kündigte für heute in Berlin eine Beratung mit Vertretern vom Innenjustiz- und Jugendministerium an. Brandenburgs Innenminister Schönburm forderte in dessen rechtsextremistische Gewalttäter Rascha zu bestrafen. Ermittlungen. Die vermisste 4-jährige Julia ist noch nach dem gewaltsamen Tod ihrer Mutter von einem Zeugen gesehen worden. Danach befand sich das Mädchen am 4. Juli und damit nach dem Verbrechen in der Wohnung eines Tatverdächtigen. Nach dem Kind wird bundesweit gesucht. Am ersten Auktionstag haben die Bieter für die deutschen Lizenzen der nächsten Mobilfunk-Generationen Verhalten begonnen. Am Abend lagen die Gebote unter 3 Milliarden Mark. Die Bundesregierung hofft auf einen wesentlich höheren Erlös. Versuch, der größte Verlag der USA, Random House, wird ab 2001 einige Bücher nur im Internet veröffentlichen. Wie die Bertelsmann-Tochter mitteilte, können die 20 Beledristik- und Sachbuchtitel dann nach Bezahlung heruntergeladen und auf Wunsch ausgedruckt werden. Formel 1, der Chef des Lausitz-Rings Fischer, rechnet nicht mehr mit dem Zuschlag für den großen Preis von Deutschland. Fischer wollte den Lauf schon ab 2002 von Hockenheim nach Ostdeutschland holen. Nachts 14 bis 10 Grad am Tag heiter, 23 bis 27 Grad.
0, 34 mit Matthias Kerkhoff, Dankeschön.
Fritz geht auf guter Sommertour zusammen mit Victoria Pan. Und mit Fritz DJ René Hausmann.
René Hausmann.
August im Kuhstall in Straußberg.
Faschmusik unterwegs in Brandenburg.
Die Musik von Flow hier im Chaosradio 52, das ist der Projektname von Dr. B Hamburg. Dafür, dass ich das so oft erwähne, kriege ich auch Geld übrigens von dem. Und zwar nicht so knapp, das weiß er mir noch nicht so genau. Unser Thema sind die Programmiersprachen.
Unser Thema sind die coolen Features. Mir ist gerade noch ein cooles Feature eingefallen.
Was denn?
Es gibt etwas in der Programmierung, das bezeichnet man als Exception Handling. Wenn ein Programm etwas tut, dann ist es in der Regel auch gezwungen, sicherzustellen, dass das, was es versucht hat zu veranlassen, auch tatsächlich durchgeführt wurde. Mit anderen Worten Dinge können auch Fehlschlagen an der Datei kann nicht gefunden werden und ähnliche Geschichten. Und in den frühen Sprachen, insbesondere in den prozeduralen Programmiersprachen, wo man halt immer so ein bisschen Spaghetti mäßig den Ansatz gemacht hat, war das immer ziemlich mühsam. Man musste halt irgendwie jeden einzelnen Schritt, den man anführt, helfen, hat er jetzt auch geklappt. Und wenn es nicht geklappt hat, was mache ich dann? Und das ganze Aufräumen von Fehlersituationen ist einfach ein ziemlicher Aufwand gewesen. Exception Handling ist halt mittlerweile auch ein abstraktes Element vieler Programmiersprachen, die sozusagen den Fehlerfall explizit abfangen und geregelt an das Programm zurückmelden, sodass man sehr viel eleganter darauf reagieren kann. Solche Fehlerfindungsmethoden sind natürlich gerade bei kritischen Anwendungen sehr wichtig. Nehmen wir mal als Beispiel einen Raketenstart.
Wie war das noch mit...
Ja, da ist die Ariane 5, sollte halt gestartet werden. Das haben sie dann auch getan. Das tolle neue Teil wurde getestet und flog dann hoch und auf einmal explodierte es. Und keiner wusste erstmal so richtig warum. Und dann haben sie halt geschaut und geschaut und geschaut. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Wochen die daran herum analysiert haben. Aber letzten Endes haben sie festgestellt, dass halt ein Programm abgestürzt ist. Es gab nämlich eine Exception. Wusstest du das nicht im Detail?
Ja, und zwar der Code, das war alles in Ada geschrieben. Das muss man vielleicht dazu sagen. Ada ist eine Programmiersprache, die gerne für Raketen und ähnliche Geschichten eingesetzt wird. Also im Raumfahrtumfeld, im militärischen Umfeld und noch ein bisschen Flugzeuge und so weiter und so fort. Und Ada ist in der Lage, eine Exception zu erzeugen, wenn Wert überläuft. Wenn ich eine Variable habe, dann hat die eine begrenzte Anzahl Bits zur Verfügung, um Wert zu speichern. Das heißt, ich kann da nicht beliebig mit rumrechnen, sondern irgendwann läuft das halt über. Und viele Sprachen erkennen das nicht. Einige Sprachen erkennen das. Und wenn man tatsächlich wissen will, ob das Ergebnis, was man jetzt errechnet hat, zuverlässig ist oder ob das Ergebnis kaputt ist, muss man halt in der Lage sein, das zu erkennen. Ada hat das getan und in Ariane 5 haben sie teilweise Code aus der Ariane 4 weiter verwendet. Und es ist so, die Ariane 5 war größer, stärker, schneller. Und da gab es irgendwo einen Wert, wo die Geschwindigkeit der Rakete gespeichert wurde. Und die Ariane 5 war schneller als die Ariane 4 und deswegen hat der Platz da nicht ausgereicht. Und dieses Stückchen Code hat aber trotzdem so getan als Ariane 4 gewesen. Es ist übergelaufen, hat eine Exception geworfen. Nur war es so, dass die Fehlerbehandlung leider fehlerhaft implementiert war. Und an der Stelle der Standard-Fehlerhändler in Kraft getreten ist. Und das, was das System halt tut, wenn eine Exception auftritt, mit der es nicht zurecht kommt, ist die Rakete zu sprengen.
Könnte das ungefähr das sein, was gerade mit unserem Real Audio Server passiert?
Beine nach oben. In dem Fall ist es sehr kontrolliert aufgetreten. Das Programm war so designt, dass die Rakete explodiert, wenn dieser Fall eintritt. Nur hat jemand vergessen, nachzusehen, wie das Design war. Im Gegensatz zu einem Real Audio Server, der wahrscheinlich einfach abgestürzt ist, weil irgendwas fehlerhaft programmiert ist.
Man kann hier auch anrufen. Uns würde immer noch interessieren, was für Programmiersprachen ihr benutzt und ob ihr vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen was Exotisches oder was richtig Exotisches benutzt. Was das dann ist und vor allen Dingen wie ihr das benutzt. Die Nummer hier ist 0331 70 97 110. Programmiersprachen ist unser Thema. Und ihr ruft hier an.
Hier ist das Chaosradio.
Danke. Chaosradio hier. Hallo.
Ja hallo.
Grüß dich. Hier ist Olli. Olli. Ja, kennt ihr die Programmiersprache Step 5?
In der Tat. Nie gehört.
Noch nie gehört?
Nein.
Das hab ich in meiner Ausbildung gelernt.
Das ist für...
Speicherprogrammierbare Steuerung.
SPS.
Für solche Siemens-Teile. Da hatte man dann so eine flüssige Entwicklungsumgebung und dann wurden das die Eingänge waren, zum Beispiel. Ah, was weiß ich.
Ganz einfache Logik implementieren, die Maschinen zu steuern.
Genau, genau.
Und auch solche, ja was weiß ich, Timereinbauen in den Sport, Sprungbefehle und all den ganzen Gramm relativ einfach zu lernen.
Man kommt das immer relativ schnell durcheinander.
Das war nicht an der ganzen Gelegenheit.
Ich hab in dem ganzen Jahr, was ich da gelernt hab, die Programmi-Sport, habe ich kein solches Programm auf der Reihe gebracht.
Du sprichst nicht unbedingt gegen deine Intelligenz, sondern eher gegen die Programmiersprache.
Jetzt tue ich relativ wenig Programm.
Ich muss das immer richtig zu Gemüte führen.
Was ich noch relativ wütlich finde, ist BrainFuck.
Der war ja ein Compiler oder Übersetzer.
Du hast ein C-Code geschrieben.
Der Übersetzt BrainFuck in C?
Ja, das ist eine gängige Methode.
Man weiß aber wenigstens, was da passieren soll, mit der ganzen Angelegenheit.
Und hast du in BrainFuck schon mal was programmiert bekommen?
Ich? Nicht unbedingt. Danke für deinen Anruf.
Step 25 war das.
Das ist übrigens ein interessanter... Das ist gerade für neue Programmiersprachen eine sehr beliebte Methode, erstmal plattformunabhängig zu werden. Weil C ist eigentlich nichts anderes als eine abstrahierte Maschinensprache. Und deswegen kann man eigentlich relativ effizient irgendeine Programmiersprache in C übersetzen, die dann eben von einem C-Compiler in tatsächliche Maschinensprache übersetzt wird. Aber so muss man eben nicht gleich von vornherein 1000 Prozessoren unterstützen, sondern man lässt den Rest halt von GCC machen, der kann das schon ganz gut.
Hi, das ist noch mal Doty von vorher. Selfie und interessante Features. Also ich nütze dir so eine Feature von Visual Studio. Und zwar ist das, wenn da ja immer der schwere Ausnahmefehler kommt, dann ist dann die neue Schaltfläche, die praktisch, wenn der Netzcap abstürzt, dann kriegt man das dann wieder weg. Aber für Visual Studio ist das für überhaupt nichts gut.
Aber immerhin, da schläft ja dieses Fenster.
Und noch Brainfuck, also Brainfuck taugt man echt wirklich, mit seinen ganzen sechs Befehlen. Und darf ich da noch kurz Werbung machen für ein Programmierprojekt von mir? Und zwar, ich probiere ein Betriebssystem vollständig in Assembler zu programmieren. Und suche jetzt so Hobbyprogrammierer, also keine Profis, weil ich kann Assembler selber nicht so gut. Aber es ist nur so, wenn ich zum Kennenlernen und so, und suche ein paar Programmierer. Und die Homepage war quicksos.org.
Programmierst du das in Assembler und nicht in einer höheren Programmiersprache?
Assembler ist ja bekanntlicherweise bis zu zehnmal schneller als C.
Das ist leider eine falsche Aussage. Es ist bis zu zehn Prozent schneller, als würde man es in C schreiben.
Aui, dann bin ich ein bisschen falsch informiert. Na, aber wenn. Wenn der Betriebssystem zehn Prozent schneller ist, dann ist man ja auch schon froh.
Ja, aber man ist auch froh, wenn man das auf einen anderen Prozessor portieren kann, dem man einfach nur den Compiler anwirft und nicht alles neu schreiben muss.
Ja, aber es gibt ein GPL Assembler OS Projekt. Ich habe aber leider den Namen vergessen.
Es gibt, wie heißt es, aber wer schon kennt, es gibt auch Assembler OS Projekte wie Sandarmeer. Und die meisten kranken halt daran, dass man in Assembler einfach nicht so lesbar schreiben kann. Und so ein Betriebssystem schon ziemlich komplexe Abstraktionen voraussetzt. Also Speicherverwaltung, Prozessverwaltung, Interprozesskommunikation. Das ist halt irgendwann echt komplizierter Assembler zu handeln und die Übersicht geht verloren. Das ist der Grund, warum die meisten dieser Projekte eingehen. Es sei denn, es sind sehr spezialisierte Betriebssysteme. Also ich erinnere mich zum Beispiel an die DOS-Extender unter DOS, wo das Betriebssystem im Prinzip ein paar K-Code waren, die den Protected Mode eingeschaltet haben und einen 32-bit linearen Speicher gegeben haben und dann den Rest dem Programm überlassen haben.
Also eine Casio-Uhr wäre etwa so eine Anwendung, wo man wirklich ein spezialisiertes Assembler Realtime OS bräuchte, was sehr kleines.
Und was man anlassen kann, dafür ein Betriebssystem in Assembler zu schreiben, ist, dass man Spaß daran hat, Betriebssystem in Assembler zu schreiben.
Ja, wie gesagt, das ist ja nur so zum Kennenlernen.
Ja eben, dafür ist das völlig okay.
Ja, das Betriebssystem, was da in Assembler geschrieben ist, das heißt V2 OS.
Okay, Otti. Alles Gute. Chaosradio 52, Musik von Flow im Internet auch abrufbar. www.bisonic.com und danach flow suchen. Und unser Thema für die letzten fünf Minuten ist immer noch dasselbe wie am Anfang der Sendung Programmier Sprachen.
Was war?
Ach ja, wir wollten telefonieren. Welche Sprachen sprecht ihr denn so? Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio.
Na, weil es einfach ist oder nicht.
Doch.
Nur einfach, sondern sinnlos.
Naja, nein, es ist nicht schlimm. Es ist nicht wirklich schlimm.
Man wird nicht aussätzig davon.
Es gibt ein Haken, gerade Visual Basic ist der Sprachumfang nicht festgelegt. Das heißt, es gibt keine Spezifikation dieser Sprache, was ganz in Ordnung ist, solange man Visual Basic 6 programmiert. Aber wenn jetzt Visual Basic 7 rauskommt, ist das Problem, dass es auch für Visual Basic 7 keine Spezifikation gibt und dass es dann halt schwierig ist, festzustellen, wo dann der Unterschied zwischen Visual Basic 6 und Visual Basic 7 ist und dann eventuell seine Programme nicht mehr laufen. Und das ist so eine unangenehme Sache. Das ist zumindest bei jedem Übergang, also von 5 auf 6 in etwa passiert. Und man kann halt, man wird halt, ich meine, das ist manchmal so ein bisschen Microsoft Strategie, immer so ein bisschen dumm gehalten an diesen Stellen, sodass man halt nicht weiß, bin ich jetzt der Blöde, der es nur nicht kapiert oder haben die mir da jetzt einfach Scheiße vorgesetzt. Und das nervt so ein bisschen. Und auch die Dokumentation ist an manchen Stellen einfach ein bisschen unklar. Entweder, ja, also das sind vielleicht die Handicaps. Ansonsten kann man sicherlich alles...
Das ist natürlich nicht portabel. Das heißt, wenn du mal von Windows weg willst, musst du eine andere Programmiersprache lernen.
Was würde Florian denn stattdessen besser nehmen, statt Visual Basic, mit dem er es selber erreichen kann?
Also Java ist sicherlich auch eine Alternative an der Stelle, wo er zumindest auch mehr Plattformen hat und was auch etwas dankbarer ist. Wobei es, wie gesagt, auch darauf ankommt, was er jetzt im Konkreten damit vorhat. Aber zum zum Lernen ist da sicherlich Java mit besseren Ausdrucksmöglichkeiten die erste Wahl.
Florian, herzlichen Glückwunsch, dass du gerade einen Verbraucherhinweis bekommen. Ja danke. Gute Nacht. So, wer ist denn da? Hier ist das Chaosradio.
NCGI, wenn bekommst du nicht alles.
Nicht mit den Pieptasten, nicht? Versuchen wir es nochmal. Chaosradio, hier bist du.
Ja, ihr sucht ja immer noch seltene Programmiersprachen. Ich meine, das Wort kennt jeder und zwar Postscript, ne? Das ist ja eine Seitenbeschreibungssprache. Aber darin kann man ja auch richtig programmieren. Es sind ja so Variablen da, es sind Schleifen, da ist alles da, ne?
Das ist eine ziemlich coole Programmiersprache.
Und es ist so ähnlich wie FORCE, ne?
Genau, Stack-Origin.
Also ich hab damals mir nämlich ein NEXT-Rechner gekauft vor 10 Jahren. Und da war das Betriebssystem auf die Pestplatte zu klein, sodass ich das Entwicklersystem zunächst nicht hatte. Und da blieb mir eigentlich nichts anderes übrig, als Postscript zu benutzen. Weil das war schon dabei, sozusagen. Da brauchte man also nur ein Aspekt. Ich hab damals nur so kleinere Programme geschrieben, mit denen man einen Kalender anzeigen konnte. Also der dann eben auch gleich auf dem Drucker und auf dem Bildschirm erschien.
Sehr beliebt. Hast du das mit den Schaltjahren korrekt hingekriegt?
Ja, ich hab damals zumindestens einfach gesagt, also das Jahr 2000 braucht keine Sonderregel. Also reicht das Programm bis 2099.
Also ich hatte mir das schon überlegt.
Und ich hab das auch wirklich jetzt noch benutzt, dieses Kalenderprogramm neulich. Weil das einen ganz praktischen, übersichtigen Kalender ausgibt.
Gut, dass du das erwähnt hast, weil die stackorientierten Programmiersprachen stehen hier auf unserem Zettel, aber wir sind noch nicht dazu gekommen.
Da werden wir auch glaub ich gar nicht mehr zu kommen, oder?
Es ist in jeden Macintosh übrigens ein Forth eingebaut, zumindest in die neueren. Wenn man Command, Option, während der Einschalt sort kommt, landet man in der Open Firmware. Und da kann man sowas eingeben wie 2 space 3 space plus space Punkt Return. Bekommt dann die Antwort 5. Man legt also mit der 2 die 2 auf den Stack, mit der 3 die 3 auf den Stack. Mit Plus addiert man die beiden oberen Stakelemente. Und mit Punkt lässt man sich das obersteck Element anzeigen, was dann das Ergebnis der Operation ist.
Ja genau, das ist ja im Fortskript so ähnlich, da hieß es dann irgendwie, weiß ich.
Oder so.
Die Befehle. Und weil wir gerade bei Next Waren, da gibt es natürlich noch ein anderes Derivat, was auch nicht über sonst kaum benutzt wird, das ist eben Objective C. Also eine objektorientierte Erweiterung von C, die viele der Vorteile von Java, also sagen wir andersrum, Java hat eigentlich einige dieser Ford, viele der Nachteile von C plus plus verhindert. Also eigentlich eine sehr kleine Erweiterung, die unheimlich viel erreicht. Also mehr in Richtung von Smalltalk.
Ja, Java hat sich eine Menge abgeguckt bei Objective C. Allerdings ist Objective C noch ein bisschen stärker, weil es irgendwie dynamisch ist. Und das Problem hat Java natürlich, ja, also dieses Vorteil hat Java nicht. Also Objective C, das ist ein interessanter Hinweis, ist eigentlich eine sehr einfache Erweiterung von C. An einer einzigen Stelle wird eigentlich ein neues Syntax aufgemacht, eckige Klammer auf, und dann programmiert man im Prinzip Smalltalk. Und das hat halt darin irgendwie seine Objekte mit Vererbung und allen Schnickschnack sehr elegant getrennt von dem C-Code, sodass man C-Code halt wie C-Code schreibt und auch nichts anderes, wie dann C++, was eine komplett neue Welt aufmacht und den wirklich objektorientiert halt einfach in Smalltalk und das ist eine sehr angenehme Syntax.
Das neue Apple Betriebssystem wird ja auch die Sprache noch benutzen, zum Teil das Mac OS X. Das war eben sehr schön, weil das wirklich im Betriebssystem verankert war. Man hatte eigentlich fast keine andere Wahl, aber man hatte auch kein Bedürfnis, eine andere Sprache zu benutzen. Weil alles damit schon funktionierte. Wenn man ein Textobjekt geöffnet hat, dann hatte man einen kompletten Texteditor mit allem drum und dran und brauchte nicht erst überlegen, wie ich das Texteinlichten, wie stelle ich den Font ein, das war alles schon da. Und das eben schon 1990. Und andere Systeme sind jetzt erst wieder so weit gekommen.
Das ist richtig, auch wenn Sie das Display brechen, auch wenn Sie das Display Postkurs jetzt irgendwie eingestellt haben.
Ich danke für deinen Anruf und für die letzte ausgefallene Programmiersprache dieses Tages oder dieser Sendung. Und sage auf Wiedersehen, das war das Chaosradio 52. Jetzt gleich gibt es einen Nightfly mit Frauke Niemeyer.
Was wir nächstes Mal machen, wissen wir noch nicht, aber warum schickt ihr uns nicht auch mal ein paar Vorschläge in Chaosradio ccc.de, was ihr meint, worüber Chaosradio sich unterhalten sollte.
Das war mal eine hübsche Idee.
Ich verabschiede mich von Tim, von Pawel, von Andreas und von Mitch, der heute kaum was gesagt hat. Die Musik kam von Dr. Bietnick oder auch sein Projektname ist Flow. Den könnt ihr euch unter Umständen unter www.bisonic.com untersucht ihr nach Flow. Ich komm gleich und hol mir die 500 Berlin Branden.